okay being
10:30 uh we'll open the uh work session
1032 is any anybody here would like to
say
something okay this bill
um as it says relative certificate of
title exemptions for vehicles over 20
years it came out of committee 170 one
on the consent
calendar uh and the funds that are
budget does anybody have anything they'
two go ahead represent thank you Mr
chairman how what is the dollar amount
is it it's 24,000 that I see here yeah
but it comes out of their current budget
you anybody else yes obviously the
original Bill set a date 2000 then
they're going forward and it becomes
you know now it's 24 you know it's it's
24 years ago so 20 years makes more
sense than just saying before the year
so seems to me it's pretty obvious that
that language need to change and that's
done yeah nobody else as much as they
like to make a motion okay like to move
to recomend to the okay do all motion
seconded do we want a show of hands that
would that be sufficient would we like
the clerk to call the
role show a hands all those in
favor okay it's
10:55
okay that will give me plenty of time to
then
e
ments and putting up unauthorized
Moorings uh administrative law requires
specific authorization for a type of
fee and they don't currently have a fee
for for replacement decals the the
original decals are covered in statute
and this um allows them to charge for
replacement it is not the same statute
as the
basic boat decals which is the subject
of the bill but we felt it
was it was close enough to use this bill
as a place to put it we Jael car
approved the rule with the
recommendation that
Department of Safety worked with various
legislators to get legislative
clarification so if you approve if you
decide to accept this amendment it will
back up the rule if you reject this
amendment the department of safety will
probably have to revise their rule
because they don't have authority to uh
charge a replacement fee I'll be glad to
answer any questions about the
rulemaking part if you have questions
about the decals we have someone from
the Department of Safety who who
understands what's going
on any questions
yes there's a couple of things that that
come to mind when I come to section two
exemption from
registration and then they put that
section in there then they don't list
anybody that's
law well it I'm not I'm not familiar
with the current with the existing law
on decals if canoes and paddle boards
have to have a registration that could
be what the exemptions
are that's in the existing law so it's
not shown would that's the only reason I
can think of they'd have the heading but
not the
uh not any
text thank
you other
questions clear's
okay any more
clarification uh I know the department
is here if we'd like to hear from them
but if not um I just wanted to mention
that um as chairwoman Maguire mentioned
that both the Senate members and the
House of Representative members
bipartisanly agreed that this would be a
good move for the for the fix and we
would appreciate your support on the
amendment
okay we have a we're going to we do have
a motion we have a motion and a second
on the amendment all those in favor of
the amendment please raise your hand
okay it's
1304 as amended as
amended do we have any discussion on
would the person that just left be the
Transportation yeah why don't you
because I mean if he we got lots of time
here the smartest guy in the room just
topic
no discuss the deal itself when we
discuss the amendment I don't have a you
say
okay well we have a motion we can have
further discussion but we have i' like
to make a motion for discuss purposes
that recomend okay we have a motion we
have a
second okay representative
okay and now we're going to wait for the
right
fast that was just the amendment now we
do you have any comments you'd like to
make about the uh what we're changing
from and two just to Enlighten us a
little bit so um just sorry and if you
could introduce yourself thank you I'm
attorney Dave hiltz I represent the New
Hampshire Department of Safety um just
be candid with you um I probably haven't
looked at the primary bill for this at
all
um if somebody has a copy of it I mean I
could take a look at it thank
you we have plenty of time okay so I I
expected Captain dunlavy to be here this
morning um and actually he was over in
house Transportation earlier and um we
were supposed to meet here but he's not
here and I don't know why so um he would
probably be able to answer your
questions much better than I could but
here I don't think anybody's wildely
opposed to anything it's just just for
enlightenment to say what are we going
from and that's yeah and Mr chair I
should also mention that I did speak
with both the acting chairman and
ranking member of ways and means about
this bill in prefacing that we'd like to
add a Germaine amendment to it for the
Jael car fix and um they they mentioned
that their work has been completed early
in the first committee before the Jael
car issue was raised so it seems like
the policy issue had been thoroughly
vetted before this gel car matter had
come up
so I mean if that gives you any sense of
how how the committee how this bill
ended up here under these circumstances
and to add to that a little it's the
bill really is about policy I don't
think we need to talk about the policy
it passed the house on a vice Voice vote
there was not a lot of a controversy and
the financial impact is basically nil
because it will cost 48 th but those
will be recouped as you know as part of
the fees that they're issuing so you
know I I don't feel that a lot of uh you
know argument discussion is needed
here um if I may Mr chairman I do have
Captain Dunley here um I think he might
be better suited to answer some
questions about the primary Bill all
excuse me I was in the
restroom Mr chairman honorable members
of the committee Tim Dunley I am uh
representing you uh the department of
safety Marine Patrol unit before you
this morning uh in regards to this bill
before you today this uh has a bit of
History I won't get into it too much
other than to say just because you're on
camera if you would like to sit down it
you there was a bit of History here
um the Marine Patrol receives about a
million and a half dollars a year from
the federal government through the Coast
Guard recreational boating safety
Grant as part of the receipt of those
funds they do an audit to make sure that
our program is complying with federal
law it was determined that during our
boat registration
process that we were including fees that
went to uh Public Access search and
rescue a dredge fund overseen by the
Port Authority in in in Portsmouth and
um funds that go to the Department of
Environmental Services for the fight
against aquatic invasive
species federal law prohibits the state
from collecting any funds other than
specific boat registration fees at the
time of that financial
transaction New Hampshire is one of
numerous states that were doing so and
as a result we got our letter from the
Coast Guard saying we need to remedy
this
process as a result um this went to
study committee uh and during study um
um chair uh representative kraton
sponsored this bill before you today to
create a second decal
program that requires a person who is
registering their boat to also purchase
a second
decal that is capturing those fees that
we can no longer charge uh with the
registration it's basically creating two
Financial
transactions and that's all the Coast
Guard is looking for is the creation of
the opportunity for a person to just pay
registration
monies and not anything
else however uh this bill is designed to
make sure ensure that the person is
still paying those
fees if that's clear as mud please let
me know go ahead question just to make
sure I understood it correctly the
purpose of the bill is to allow you to
operate the same way you've done before
but with a proper legislative backing
and with a minor headache of now having
to do two decals and two transactions
instead of one like we used to be
precisely and the only difference in
fees that the individual will pay from
five years ago or if this bill passes
when it's implemented is an additional
$3 to cover the cost of that second
decal that is all that is before you as
far as uh a change in any fees that the
the consumer the boat owner will see
it's not changing who has to register
it's not changing the the amount of the
fees that have been collected for our
instate Partners all these years it's
just separating um the collection of
those fees that are currently in
violation of federal law this is a nosy
question how long have you been doing
how long has this process taken just out
of curiosity uh we've been doing this
for well I started in the late 80s with
the Marine Patrol and it's been that way
the fees have changed no I'm saying this
this pulling it apart so you got a new
decal when did the Coast Guard get after
you about that uh we're now uh well they
went to they went to study first so
we're we're in our fourth year okay
that's F I was just curious yeah yeah
any question yes oh this is just sort of
a more of a comment as a question
wouldn't it since other states are
involved dare I say wouldn't it have
been easier if the Coast Guard had
changed their rule
no I'm told as a federal agency that is
a a tremendously
long uh uh process I will say in closing
that because we are not the only ones
and uh our partner agencies as well as
the department of safety here in state
are working with Senator Shaheen's
office at the federal level with other
states to remedy the current language in
federal statute that being said we know
what that process may or may not look
like in time so we've got two parallel
courses um we're encouraged by what
we're seeing at the federal level uh
however representative kraton did not
want to back off our efforts here for
fear that if the feds take a little
longer it it could jeopardize uh our
partners
funding representative wer I'm still
curious about the bill we have says
exemption from registration but it
doesn't list anybody is that because
we're only seeing an incomplete part of
that
bill uh no you're you're seeing it all I
think the exemption from registration
was just from certain fees and it's
because there's a second decal being
added they're not technically
registration fees any longer so I think
that's that perhaps is the reason for
the language you don't have to register
canoes and paddle boards right that is
correct and none of that is changing all
exemptions from registration that exist
today will continue to exist thank you
just to again make sure I understand it
correctly the language the only change
we see is in the heading of the chapter
because the body is left unchanged and
therefore doesn't need to be listed we
just list what we change and we are just
changing the title to include the new
decal references and all that so okay
thank
you and and you'll recoup the this has a
a a fiscal note of
$48,000 and that's buy the initial
inventory and stuff that's exactly right
and Mr chair did did are you also
mentioning that or taking
um um are you're also noting I should
say that the fiscal note was amended
that thought because the initial bill if
it goes into effect would only be a half
year um so it would be 24,000 in the
first year and then 48 in the following
years thereafter right that's that's
what I've got but it comes out of the
fund yeah yeah so it's really to us it's
fun okay thank you sir thank you very
much appreciate it okay we have a motion
for the bill as amended all those in
favor raise your
hand okay
unanimous
okay we now have until 11:20 whoa we're
pretty pretty close here I'll be darn
right on here while there's money in the
fiscal note the actual bill is
authorization just the authorization
looking for the Department of Education
will have to come back to to the fiscal
committee actually to fund
execution uh and and we know we know
that the education trust fund has
sufficient money so that's a nice
approach do anybody have anything you
like to comment on the bill itself
yes representative Heath thank you Mr
chair I just would like to hear about
from Amy about how she sees this rolling
absolutely good morning for the record
my name is Amy Clark and I work for the
Department of Education in the school
facilities Bureau and I believe my
program would be responsible for rolling
this out uh if we had funds to do so um
the bill uh the current Law requires us
to do this facility assessment study
this is just a um if you can see above
um on that Amendment there's already um
language that requires us to do so this
is just adding additional clarification
language I I think that uh
representative lad may maybe thought was
necessary so uh but we still don't have
funds for performing this study that's
been required by um the agency for a
couple couple of years now one or two
years
this uh Mickey do you know do you know
what why this is showing in 2025 $75
revenue is that on the fiscal note yeah
um I think the if I is your fiscal note
dated the 21st of
February no so you should have one dated
the 21st of February for the bill as
amended how it how it passed the house
committee
what's the number of the of that house
bill 1570 if you don't have it I have
well
thank
you
okay so this one
so that 75 million
disappeared
right not that this changed a lot
uh yeah yes represent Heath so just a
question um I remember
Years Gone by in school approval um
school districts were supposed to do
some kind of an assessment of their
buildings there as part of the school
approval
process um many years ago probably it's
changed since because staffing has been
reduced
um so this would replace and authorize
the department to do an assessment
and to hire the necessary people to do
it would there be a um a sequence of of
years
or so I'm not familiar with the prior
assessment I'm not familiar that the
state has at one time the state did do
um somewhat of a self assessment for
facilities um and uh we have that in
paper form I think it was done maybe in
the '90s uh and schools check checked
off whether they had a boiler and HVAC
system what type of roof they had it was
more like a survey uh per se uh and but
since that time there's been no fac this
is a Statewide facility assessment and
again the requirement is already in law
this bill just adds some clarification
to that but there still is no funding to
complete that assess assessment so if
the state wants us to be able to
complete that we will somehow need to
get funding to do
so
I I think the funding source was the
educational trust fund and and my
thought process on this is it's looking
for somebody
to interview Consultants or
subcontractors and come up with a number
and then go to the fiscal committee and
say here's the number I that that that's
what we've been have dialogue about I
don't
know does that make sense um I'm not
sure that does but uh um I have not been
privy to that okay uh information but um
we have look I could be making this all
up I I'm not sure what our next step
would be uh um if we had uh funding to
perform the assessment we certainly
would uh put out a RFP for that and
before we found out the exact dollar
amount right um we have um in the
ballpark we have about 15 cents a square
foot we know that it'll approximately
cost lost 15 cents to 20 20 cents a
square foot we have about 33 million we
actually don't know how many square feet
we have because we don't have an
assessment but we estimate we have about
33 million square feet that that's about
$5 million for the assessment on
potentially the low end question not as
a qu not as much of a question as a
suggestion since you know in order to
perform this before the new budget year
which would be a long way down the road
the funding has to be approved by the
fiscal commit ittee maybe you know it
would be best if you uh contacted the
fiscal committee to ask them exactly
what is the process they'd like to see
before you come in front of them to
request funds and I'm sure they'll be
happy to provide you with proper
guidance yes yes and the commissioner
may have um started that process as well
okay question does this bill give you
the authority is is that what this is
looking for the authority to go to
fiscal no that well whatever the
language is they're that they're adding
they already have the ability to do
that rep I those questions are good for
representative lad I I'm not sure you
intend no language is needed to
authorize that they can go to the fiscal
committee for you know any need for
additional funding that was not part of
the budget process that's authorized by
law and part of their mandate so adding
new language would be you know we got
the chairman right here he could tell us
exactly
oh yes so just to remind everyone fiscal
doesn't have the ability to just
appropriate money to any agency who
requests it there are statutory
authorizations for that so this this
program I don't believe
uh I think if you wanted to make it very
clear for the Department of Education
had the authority to access education
trust funds through fiscal I would add
it to this bill so currently under
current law they've got the ability to
go to fiscal to access funds if they are
short to administer School building Aid
payments it could be argued that's not
what this is so I think if you wanted to
have your position be that this is uh
the policy is that they could come for a
warrant through approved by fiscal to do
this project or this uh assessment I
think it might be best to add it to this
bill so sound the
probably the thing to do is prepare an
amendment so that we if it's the if it's
the division's intent to allow the
department to go to fiscal to seek funds
to do this assessment you could add it
to this RSA and sense we're really not
approving anything I mean yeah I mean
like I said there there is an RSA 19839
an ability for doe to come to fisal if
they to administer state aid programs
like to disperse funds I I'm not sure
it's necessarily completing this
assessment but at least that way you'd
be covered the department would be
covered and have a clear just by a show
a hands how many people would like to
get that Amendment propos preped okay so
can you get get us an amendment I don't
know when we're going to meet again
because we got elections next Tuesday
and I don't know if we have we don't
14 Okay so we've got a little bit of
time all right yeah yeah thank you Mr
chair um one or two questions depending
on the answer to the first um how long
how effective what's the the the shelf
life of doing an assessment of each
building in terms of how long how
valuable is that over time and the other
thing is if it says an additional 250 to
500,000 each year to the aafter T date
so this would be an ongoing project as
well and so it's not a matter of the
shelf life of the of the project it
becomes self-correcting as you you're
nodding so that's a um it's actually a
very great point because there are
cheaper options where you can do uh one
time and be done it's that data just
gets outdated so fast so for it to be
any use for us for the state to for
planning purposes it really does have to
have a ongoing maintenance cost of um
you know I Envision a system where
schools are able to update annually the
systems that they've added any kind of
capital projects that they've added if
they've replaced roofs or anything like
that that they can log in and update
that
information yes and well they have staff
to do that I mean some of the schools
are very small
um some are you know they're very some
are very large um do they have the staff
to maintain updating this or if it's a
very large school perhaps the Department
of Education would have to help out a
little bit um it just seems like you
have a wide variety of abilities and um
attributes of different schools uh I
believe it's not a huge undertaking for
the facility manager every district has
for most for the most part um every
district has a facility manager and they
are this is these are their projects um
so I don't foresee that they that it
would be a a large burden to update that
year so the and also that information is
part of the CIP for the town correct
correct it's it's actually critical
information that the school needs to
talk to their school boards and
everything about the status of their
school
right
yes do you need any other authority to
conduct this
um just um in the amendment the
authority to go to fiscal but also the
authority to conduct this first review
and then annual updates do you want
something in this bill that would say
what should look
like
I the more I guess that would be up to
you all from my take the more specific
driven from those of us that are not
fully um sure what the proposals will be
it seems like um putting out those rfps
seeing what comes back what is actually
useful information would be good to have
that flexibility in there um but if
there's something specific that the
state wants to see in there um so to
back up there's there's something called
the facility condition index it's it's a
standard um number that it's calculated
a couple of different ways by different
organizations but it's a standard
um term in the industry and that's
really what we would be looking for is
that facility condition index as well as
that is for any type of building right
you could do a facility condition index
of this building it would take in a
bunch of factors and you'd get this
number which tells folks in the
industry how well the building is doing
and the life of the equipment and what's
going to break down next um there's also
what I think is really important is the
educational suitability um of a building
as well um the example would be you can
have a bu bowling alley that has a
excellent facility condition index
doesn't make it suitable for an
educational facility so when we when
other states look at this they're
usually looking at the condition of the
facility and the suitability um of
educational
purposes and we don't have anything like
that right now we we do not thank
you yes uh while we're on the the
subject it's not on this bill but uh
construct building construction or
building Aid um
applications
so I've noticed that school district
gives away buildings and then asks us to
to build new building shouldn't they be
required to
maximize the value of of the buildings
they're discontinuing and sell them so
that money can be used for the new
building
I'm not familiar of that happening um
our building Aid has been very limited
over the past um decade U plus um I'm
not familiar with that being a
substantial issue with the um buildings
themselves when they turn them over
every town is different um if they were
to sell the building and make a profit
that actually um does get reporting on a
building aid application and the amount
of state aid is reduced by that amount
if they're rolling it over into a
municipal they their local taxpayers
already then um I know that they yeah
the local taxpayers supposedly own the
building but if they give it away the
Boys and Girls
Club that's not a local tax organization
it's not so it would seem to be wrong if
you're just giving away this building
that you might have got a couple million
for then you come to West and ask for
more Millions right so the building Aid
has a requirement in the law that the
building be used for at least 20 years
for educational purposes or they have to
pay the building Aid back um so but
beyond that I mean if um beyond that the
law just requires that to be 20 years
and another instance I heard of where
they they were selling a building and
the only offer was a charart of school
which we have in law they're supposed to
be the first ones they refused to sell
it to
them they should then be not eligible
for any building AG
uh I think there's a new law that
requires uh charter schools to have
first right of refusal for buildings and
perhaps that was prior to that law but
there's now a law that requires after
that law yeah well that's a legal issue
for that school then for not complying
with the law but I think they should be
exempt they should they should not get
any building
Aid if they're not obeying the law I
think that should be also in the
criteria how you select that's a fair
statement but it isn't right
uh we do not have a law specific to
Charter Schools violating the law that
requires them first right of refusal to
you Micky do you have enough for
amendment I guess the one thing I'd want
to clarify is would you want that
Authority for the Department to go to
fiscal to be in perpetuity or just to
bridge you until the next budget so just
to be for fiscal 25 only and then they
would just budget this contract moving
forward Li yeah yeah limited so it'll be
a budget item in the future I I think
they'd like it the other
item question and the whole point of
going to fiscal committee is that we are
asking them to do this off budget you
know in in the middle of a budget rather
than during a budget otherwise we would
not even have this discussion so you
know the safe choice is to just
authorize them on a temporary basis and
then we'll catch it in the next budget
cycle I mean works for
me any other comments well we have we
have to yes oh I just had a question if
the committee has a strong sense of
whether or not we should include the two
measurements that Mrs M Clark was just
condition or the educational
suitability is that something we should
try to include or is that too much
policy I don't I'm not smart enough to
say yes and I'm not smart enough to say
no okay
so if I may suggest you know thinking
about it I would be hesitant to
prescribe to the department exactly how
they got to do their job circumstances
change statutes are a pain in that wish
to update if a better index comes along
I would expect that Department to go use
it instead of so I I would rather not be
that
prescriptive okay so we have I would say
fortunate or unfortunately we have a
motion on the floor made second it but
table if well I think we'll just suspend
the motion we'll consider this our next
work session Mr chair it it has been
practice of the division before to vote
knowing I'm drafting an amendment I'll
draft it based on your wishes that way
you don't have to have another work
session on this if we've done that
before well we're going to have to have
another work session on a couple other
ones anyway okay if yes if it's an easy
enough Amendment sounds like it might be
perhaps it'd be ready by the afternoon
and we could come back to this no our
head so I can withdraw my motion okay
and so we'll just consider this at our
next work session we be have due notice
thank you thank you very much we and
maybe we'll see you
again
okay we have five minutes until our
morning
so this bill coming up also has a
revised fiscal note just so everyone has
that uh if you didn't have it before
that packet I just passed around has all
the revised fiscal notes so you may have
some duplicates now but at least you
have
everything
yeah
11:45 I'll open the work session on uh
House Bill
1202 having to do with permits for
driveway
Cuts anybody like to make any comments
on this
bill
please
good morning almost afternoon I'm
representative Alexander from gtown um
so to put a little bit of perspective on
this bill this bill is a product of the
bipartisan work of the special committee
on housing um this bill would place a
reasonable timeline on Das to sign or
not Das do to sign driveway permits um
as they're related to residential
Housing Development so um representative
mccon is here to kind of give the story
of after I dropped the bill off in
public works hands um what they ended up
doing with it I know they condensed it
um amended it a little bit to just
relate to residential uses but um this
bill mainly is a product of the need for
um a faster more efficient way to get
permit signed um this was something that
we heard in the special committee and as
you see this bipartisan co-sponsor list
um it puts a reasonable timeline on dot
um the amount of permits they in they
indicated this effects is such a small
amount that I think this could help move
the ball in the right direction if we um
pass this bill so I I'm going to let
represent makoni speak to how it was
amended I think the fiscal Noe is a
little bit lower now than it was before
um so I'm I'm going to kind of refer let
him um speak more to that um
additionally I have an amendment to this
it's so minor it's a technical change um
basically
the um there was an incorrect paragraph
mentioned um by OS um this just
references the right paragraph So This
is a technical error OS couldn't make
the change because it's already passed
the house unanimously on consent so um
again this is really important bill I
think it'll help streamline the housing
process and approval so I hope that
you'll support it no matter what the
fiscal note looks like thank
you
okay
additional
comments good morning Mr chairman Steve
members of
Finance um when this when this bill
first came to Public Works in
highways uh it had a larger scope uh TR
after um the mention of uh
representative Alexander uh the special
committee on housing that was set up by
the speaker and we' met for months
nearly a year uh to discuss what were
detriment to Bringing housing forward
and we looked at all the Departments
department environmental services do uh
land planning and so forth and an
overriding
um mention kept coming from
developers uh was that it was taking
such a long time to get a driveway
permit uh from the department and um I
fully
understand um you know being coming from
a rural area some of our specifications
uh roads and things are a lighter Duty I
fully understand that some of these
projects are from down south where it's
more congested but I offer to you that I
have Conway and other areas in my group
that are are complicated also after
hearing the department uh talk about how
much energy this was going to take to
make a wholesale change to their
permitting
process um we had paired this project
down and said we will take one piece at
a time the the housing uh was a is a
high priority for those on this
committee and the speaker and so we said
well let's just look at driveway permits
for this very specific person uh for
this purpose which is including
multifamily
development um proposed residential land
including multifam development we went
we went on to ask the department so it
takes a lot of time we understand that
how much of percentage of time does this
take from your department of all the all
the permitting that you need to do and
if I remember correctly the department
had said that this was at most 1% of the
volume for for um for their
department
so I I fully understood that you know we
could pair this down and this sounds
like a simple place to start and the
original proposal when it came forward
the department thought it was going to
take at least seven more Personnel to
handle that the the whole scope uh but I
was unaware till I walked in here today
and it my mistake um that the department
is still calling for four Personnel to
handle something that is less than 1% of
of their um of their
workload and I fully understand that it
takes more but the governor and the
speaker and many people uh in this
legislature believe that moving forward
with housing projects sooner than later
is is a good a good thing to do there
was a second change in this propos
proposal because there was a concern
that we weren't giving the planning
boards enough time so lines 28 to 30 I
have I've not had a chance to look
through representative Alexander's
Amendment but I'm sure it's warranted uh
saying that the planning board that
shall not be subject to the timelines in
paragraph two and uh in their review I'm
paraphrasing shall not exceed 65 days so
I don't
um I don't
I from my time here in the
house many times physical notes are
generated by the
department and I love this department
don't get me wrong I've been in public
works and highways for nine terms I came
in in 2002 I have nothing but the utmost
respect but I I feel it's a
priority and
um if if language needed to be amended
that we're to say a once a complete
application was presented to do that
that time still remained at 30 days I
think that would go to appeasing uh the
department somewhat and would be a more
reasonable request so with that I'm
happy to take
questions just thank you Mr for
testifying and for taking questions the
last thing you said is kind of a you
know bit of a concern to me because I
understand that the department is in a
tough position if they receive an
incomplete application and the timeline
starts that's fair but would that make
it possible for the Department to keep
resetting the timeline by just
continuing to ask for new and du
documents when they may not necessarily
be there I'm I'm trying to balance it
between making it too harsh or too LAX I
I I thank I thank you representative for
the question I and there is that
possibility but if if I
can move off that Center for a moment if
I could Mr chairman Department of
Environmental
Services um had in subsurface had a
regulation back in the 80s that said the
department uh shall approve uh an
application brought forward in 30 days
and what the department was doing
routinely then was doing exactly what
the representative suggested they would
wait till the 29th day and then they
would issue something's missing
something needs to be
corrected that was that was that brought
more legislative legislation forward and
um but what's happened in the department
environmental services is they've moved
that timeline now to 24 to 48 hours they
weren't told to do it in that time frame
but they've become that efficient
because holding up families from having
a septic system or a failed septic
system and and I offer it and if the
department if I if the uh finances does
not agree I would withdraw that
suggestion I have I have faith enough in
the department that uh I believe it's a
good faith judgment we're pushing them
to 30 days we know we know that's a
number but we don't aspire to do
something until we're given a
deadline
question we've had experience in our
town recently that they waited for a
driveway permit and then word came down
you're going to need to put in a traffic
light and of course you would have to
pay for all the expenses and the lane
widening and so on and so forth and and
of course they were not able to reply to
that right away so it was like a year to
go back and having refiguring on
everything and and you know that that
kind of thing there ought to be some
warning if you're going to be coming out
from the traffic light instead of wait
till the last minute say nope no permit
till you put in a traffic light it seems
unreasonable thank
you thank you representative question
yeah um can you point me to the
difference between the amendment and the
small got it thank thank
you
you made a You made a comment I'm on the
planning board and have been for a long
time and the the operative word there
was an accepted complete
plan
so the 65 days is the same amount of
time the planning board has in statute
now okay once once they have agree they
have a complete plan the question is can
applicant can a developer come with an
incomplete plan to make a request a
driveway
request I um I the Departments here
could probably answer that better I'm
I'm I would assume that that might be a
possibility other
questions yes thank
you someone from the Department would
like
right good morning chairman uh committee
members my name is Mike citus I'm the
director of operations at nire do um
specifically to that question yes you
can file and routinely we do find uh
incomplete applications um normally the
basic application
uh is a form that's filled out uh but
then you also need to provide Deeds to
show how that particular parcel uh was
in 1971 so that you can see if you're
eligible for um your own driveway or not
as well as you need to provide some kind
of documentation we prefer a sketch uh
of site distance you need to have at
least the minimum sight distance one of
the things that goes in with that sight
distance piece also that a lot of people
misses the driveway should be at the
safest location you may have 400 feet
but there may be a safer location for
that um so that's that's one of the the
places we get hung up on um that's for a
basic single family driveway which is
also the basis for uh if you go up to
anything larger uh a major generator
when you go to a major generator there's
another section our policy and you come
up with additional material usually it's
trip generation you know basically you
want to know what kind of volume of
traffic are you going to be generating
or expecting to generate from that and
where are they going um that basic you
know those two pieces kind of help you
decide is there going to be an impact
and are you going to need
mitigation and that's that's kind of the
the big pieces that we we work
towards um you know I guess what we try
to set and there's uh in our process now
you basically file an application if
it's a major generator which is usually
anything over six six uh residential
unit subdivision or commercial you would
go to a scoping meeting um which would
have people invited from our traffic
Bureau Highway design uh might be
environmental uh we us try to invite the
town representatives and other
stakeholders but they that basically
sets the information that's going to be
required ired to support that
application once that information comes
in The Next Step would be to review the
traffic study because basically that's
going to tell you how much traffic you
might need to
mitigate once you figure out once they
approve the traffic study you take a
look at mitigation it maybe in in many
cases you don't need any but if there is
mitigation you really need to Define
what that is right at the beginning like
you said so you don't get halfway
through it find out oh there's more you
need to do you know we want to set right
at the 30% or right at the beginning
what is the mitigation required and then
you go through that final design process
which the final design process can be
lengthy you know our opinion is if
you're going to do work in the state
RightWay it should be to the same
criteria that we hold any consultant or
any engineer that does work in our right
away which when you get to different an
engineering firm some that are Highway
you know have Highway design
capabilities they understand that some
that do more let's say in the uh design
phase or or offsite you know site work
they don't have quite the same
constraints that a highway design does
so um I don't know if that helps y
question now here we're going to make a
decision on money so we've had a fairly
mild winter there should be some Surplus
in the highway fund is it possible this
Surplus in the highway fund could be
used to fund this until the next
winter
um that that's a finance question I
guess I can't I'm not sure about that i'
have to talk with our finance folks and
see you know using that money seem to
have the flexibility to be able to do
that rather than you know whole new
propriation the fiscal note actually
says Highway fund yeah
your question is there enough funds in
the highway well I'm assuming the usual
seven or eight million in a in a mild
winter in Surplus well I don't know if
we'll quite get that far but yes we will
have our projection right now is
assuming we don't have anything out of
the ordinary which I still expect at
least one more storm we will have a
surplus to it yeah thank you
representative thank you Mr chair in the
fiscal note it says depending upon the
type of permit applied for the deadline
shall be 30 or 45 days for which failure
to act by the deadline will result in
the issuance of a permit by
default that sounds very dangerous to me
that's one we'd like to avoid I mean
basically we we try to avoid denials
right off the bat um but I'm
unfortunately that's kind of what we
think it might result in more denials
versus working with the contractors to
or the developers to to kind of work out
some of the issues um again what we like
to say is we're not the only force in
the application it really depends um a
lot on the engineers and the applicants
that are submitting information the more
complete the information is the more
accurate the you know the quicker the
review times are going to be just just a
followup um with regard to your
statement about um whether or not the
driveway would be in the best loc the
safest location who determines that um
you know we give a lot of latitude to
our district engineers and our field
staff um they base that a lot on site
distance um but they also base it a lot
on what they're getting reported from
the field Crews you know if there's a
location that seems to I don't know have
an issue that they they want avoid they
might try to to move it away um so it's
it's a lot to do with our our district
office you provides that and one more
thank you thank you for being so patient
with me um in terms of the four
positions do you believe that with those
four positions New Hampshire is in a
crisis in terms of housing we all every
Community M Manchester we we all are
short of of housing units with the four
additional position i s do you believe
that you could comply with the timeline
presented um it's going to be very
difficult I I don't know for
residentials it will be very difficult
we have talked about how to do it um you
know there are some some ways there are
certain thresholds we think we could
take a look at that we won't need
mitigation that if the material comes in
complete we may be able to take a look
at uh complying with that within 30 days
um at least getting through and and you
know we have basically the the six
sections or six criteria if you can get
through and provide a pretty good
traffic impact study to begin with and
we can show no mitigation the last P
well you don't have to go through
mitigation or design so the last pie
really is making sure that you have or
certify you have all your
permits uh basically making sure if you
have any impacts any place that you uh
for utilities that you have the
utilities relocated in there and any
easements um that's at that point we
could probably either issue the permit
or you know the conditions in the permit
so in those cases we think we could
probably do it part of the reasons why
we still want are looking for four um
additional positions as well as within
that uh funding source is funding our uh
we we use a lot of Consultants now
historically we've always used uh cons
traffic staff from our traffic Bureau
and Highway designers from our project
development staff um those are not no
longer really use uh we can't really
schedule them they've got so many other
priorities now um that we've had to go
and start using more Consultants um so
we've you know spend about
135,000 on getting Consultants to do
design review for us and we need to
continue that in order to you know look
at again when you have a a you know a
couple hundred major traffic plans or
traffic permits a year we still need
that consultant assistance as well as
replace those people historically that
we had from from Highway design some
from traffic and then somebody to
basically get out in the field and do
the field work those are the people that
we still need in there if we're going to
expedite and again it's I we're looking
at somewhere between currently about 60
uh residentials I can foresee if you
pass this that number is going to go up
but if we're going to expedite those
we're going to be jumping those permits
over people that are already in the
queue for reviews so in order to you
know we can't just look at those
specific residentials to jump we need to
make sure everybody else gets in the
review so again that's why we've left
that consistent is we're trying to take
measures to move everything forward
represent
just to revisit an issue I discussed a
bit earlier you mentioned you know
complete application and again I
understand the need to have that
information but at the beginning when
you describe the application
process I understood you to say that for
a major generator you need a scope
meeting which will set the information
needed to support application that leads
me to believe that if I'm a major
generator I cannot just have the
documentation ahead of time cuz I
haven't gone through the scope meeting
so now I got to wait for the scope
meeting to happen then I know what I
need then I got to produce that and then
my clock would start if we decided on
the complete application this seems to
be amazingly excruciatingly slow is it
possible in any way for the Department
to make it clear exactly what is the
appropriate documentation based on type
of project ahead of time so hopefully
you know reduce the need for scope
meetings or is that something that's
just
essential to how your process works uh
thank you that's a good question uh the
the type of material is all laid out in
the um driveway design manual or the our
policy and you know most people if
you're doing a major you've got an
engineering firm and they know generally
what's being provided what we generally
see now is the appli application comes
in and they'll submit you know some
additional documentation like you know a
a traffic impact study and
that based on that basic guidance is
what they used to start with the scoping
study is say okay this is you're going
in the right direction but here's
additional material one of the things
we've talked about um just kind of ball
U you know spitballing in there is um do
we move for these residential ones do we
move the meeting ahead of the time to
lay out what the requirement is that's
something similar to what they do with
one of the wetlands permits is 30 to 90
days ahead of submission they have a
meeting and lay out what's required so
we have talked about doing something
similar um and again that would be
something these people that you know the
new staff would be
handling thank you just as a quick
followup so I I don't want to
misunderstand what you said but I think
what you said is
basically we couldn't really tell them
exactly what is needed without going
through the scope meeting before or
after somehow you have to figure out
what what they're design what they're
planning to do in order for us to come
up and give you what we need to have for
it so if you've if you've got let's say
um a Dunkin Donuts very large generator
but a small site you know that might
have a different requirement then if
you've got a large site let's say a
large box that uh that it's going to
generate a bunch of traffic so so what
we try to do uh before the scoping
meeting is get an idea what is it you're
planning what what size development so
we have a better idea of what to ask for
so it's that it's there is always a go
you know back and forth that's just part
of the design I appreciate it I'm uh
just going to probably bother you
offline because I'm still I'm an
engineer I in my world stuff can be
defined if you document it properly
enough ahead of time I I understand more
about the complexities but I don't want
to take the committee's time for that so
please don't leave without me giving you
a business card thank you
okay other
questions yeah thank you Mr chair you
have alluded to this but I would think
in more um plain language if you could
talk to me um is I know there is
situations you regarding here but I'm
also thinking crosswalks where you have
your guidelines and this is where it
needs to be and it's totally unusable
for the person who's asking for this to
be done so can you speak a little bit of
how you work back and forth pushing back
and forth with the person who is
requesting this to match your guidelines
when if they followed your guidelines it
it would be of no use to the person
who's making the request does that make
do you understand I guess what I'm
asking I think so and normally you know
um that's again where we engage our
traffic Bureau they have SE guidelines
they'll usually go out in the field and
talk with the people that are requesting
it um we do have guidelines and a lot of
those are kind of laid out from the
mutcd or other guidance documents but
you know that is where we we rely on our
traffic bureau's um experience and and
consistency and again those would stay
the same you know that we would I don't
want to say that we're going to take our
traffic Bureau and Highway design
completely out of the equation but we
can't rely on them in a timely fashion
because they have primary jobs that are
you know we just can't pull them off to
to work on our projects so we need
somebody that we can fully be scheduling
ourselves to do this
work okay
question thank you Mr chairman so I'm
looking at the docket here on this bill
and it this this bill came out of
committee 18 to zer1 on consent and then
was passed on the floor in a Voice vote
so somebody's looking at this and saying
the department can do all this but at
the same time it
says a failure to act within the
deadline will issuance of a permit by
default can't have that we would prefer
not to what
so at this point I it looks you have
you're asking for four positions it's is
that going to is that going to resolve
all those issues is it going to be
enough to it's I mean 30 days is a short
time I think we put in there to be
honest with you we we have a lot of
vacancies that's part of what's giving
us our problem we're requesting these
positions to be dedicated straight to
what we do right do we think we can fill
them I I would like to say yes but I
don't think so so again we are going to
have to what we try to do is explain
what we need to do this you know to try
to make a great faith effort in in
accommodating this without doing it we
will still try I mean we'll we'll work
on it I will say the first thing is if
we have to prioritize residential there
are projects that are in the queue that
are going to get delayed I mean that's
just goes because we got the same people
working on it um so some of the bigger
major projects that are already don't
like the timeline are going to get
lengthened out um and we will try to
work with folks but again 30 days is
going to be it's going to be tough I
won't say not all of them can't be again
the big cons the big idea is does it
warrant is it going to need mitigation
once it needs mitigation it pretty much
is going to be a longer process um but
we can work and try to come up with ways
that we can better Define that early on
and maybe there's a good portion that
might
work thank you I just um I wonder what
the discussion was in committee that
allowed this to come through and said
you got to issue by default
yeah again that doesn't seem right to me
again we at the department and we've got
a possibly a slanted view but we look at
this as you know U the permit is really
our way to kind of protect the uh the
The public's investment in the state
transportation system and you know we
think that although we will admit our
system does get a bit cumbersome and
it's gets laborious but we like to look
at it that we're trying to
you know make sure that if if you're
developing you know we're putting things
we're trying to make it as safe and have
least impact on Mobility that we can and
unfortunately that takes some time to
look at thank
you question it's more of a statement I
think uh and I plead guilty to doing the
same thing we kind of Dove deep into the
WIS on policy here and again I'm guilty
of the same at the end of the day this
is uh you know Finance too and this
policy has already been voted on by the
house in rather U impressive manner so
uh I think that you know we are at a
point where I I kind of had an idea of
what the department can ask for I
understand the complexities of using of
even finding those positions but I also
trust the department to be able to uh
you know find ways to achieve the
mission that the legislation is the
legislature is asking them to do so I'm
happy to stop of
myself sorry just one final question in
terms of liability for the state does
this have an impact do you believe on
projects that have had permits provided
that haven't had the due diligence that
probably you would like to see that's
that's a concern of ours I think we
would review them and I'd like to say
that you know any that we had that kind
of concern we would deny you
know I've only heard two numbers that
really stuck with me one was uh one this
is 1% of your
workload uh and and the the request is
for
$600,000 a year for four people for 1%
of your workload is that well again it's
that's what I was trying to say is it's
not just just those four people would
not not be just looking at the
residentials these are four that it's
probably closer to uh I don't know four
to 500 that they would be looking at
they'd be working on all you know
there's we the majority of our our
permits come in as you know single
family residential those we try to
handle and we we can handle those pretty
quickly they do require some some
handholding sometimes because residents
aren't used to going through the deed
process um they're not used to some of
the things but it's the major projects
you know we have a lot more of those uh
commercial projects that those these
four additional Pro uh positions would
also be working on
them basically because moving the
residential ones ahead are going to
delay them so and we would agree that
these four are needed so that we can
move those projects faster you know so
this is this this isn't just for these
those the the residentials this is in
order to get the whole process moving
which includes the
residentials question U more of a
comment Mr chair I guess uh it's worth
it's worth reflecting as a committee um
that we are not the policy committee we
are the finan finance committee so you
know to keep that perspective in mind
but also to remember that solving the
housing crisis is going to be more than
a silver bullet right so each step that
we can take in many departments across
the state to help address the situation
although maybe incremental um will be an
important piece of of moving Us in the
direction of solving those problems so
you know for me the calculus is does the
fund have the ability to support this
additional
change and if it does I feel like we
should be you know supportive of it
given that the policy committee has
already spoken firmly um so I I just
wanted to redirect our thought process
well I agree and according to this it
comments anybody want to make a anybody
want okay thank you Mr chair I move that
pass
motion oh we need to amend we need to
accept the amendment first yes for about
the amendment amendment number
H seconded if you need one
okay so the the uh uh vote is on the
adopting the amendment that has a change
in it but I I'm kind of at a loss of
ah okay thank you that's all right this
isn't all those in favor of the
amendment okay
unanimous now we have a motion made in
second it
for but to pass as amended as
amended is that seconded second okay
amended I think it's unanimous no no no
more than one two
NOS
okay all right how much thank you and
we'll see you back here at 1
vote
e
okay being 1 o00 we'll open the work
session
1288 relative to certain due process
rights for
students would anybody like to comment
on this
means um so I um I'm not sure that I
have a lot more to say than what I said
you know when we when this was debated
on the floor I think that um there are a
number of states and I think it's
increasing that have um that have these
kind of bills um the the language in the
one that's you know that is in this in
this bill um that I believe it is
drawn mostly from AR I drew it mostly
from Arizona there's Arizona Florida
Arkansas
and
I'm trying to remember what there there
was another state but I I looked at all
of them I maybe Oklahoma I think that um
Arizon is one was the one that seemed to
be to me to be uh the best you know the
best sort of language and so I drew it
it's not completely word for word from
Arizona but it's it's close and it's
basically designed to ensure that um
there are due process
protections um in for for students and
faculty members student
organizations and I think it's
um you know I it's there are 10
basically 10 sort of rights that I think
it's hard would it be hard to argue why
any of those rights are not important to
have before somebody faces um adverse
action and I think I think one of the
things I think is really important to
understand is that partic let's take
particularly with students but I suppose
it can be faculty members too
even though this is you know a um a a a
an education proceeding as opposed to
like a criminal trial or even a civil
lawsuit the consequences of that can be
really significant I mean somebody you
know particularly take take the example
of sex sexual assault somebody is
somebody is accused of having sexually
assaulted somebody and it let's assume
it doesn't go to a criminal case or it
doesn't go to a a civil case but there's
been been a f in made um that's that
that that happened I mean I could you
know that could have very very
significant uh consequences to
somebody's life later on and so I think
that we ought to we ought to want we
ought to all have an interest in making
sure that um those decisions are
reliable and you know I take the I the
sexual assault thing is the is is
probably the epitome of where this can
be a problem because you know having
been a judge and having sat on a lot of
those ca cases where they were criminal
cases it's almost always he said versus
she said that's just reality the reality
of the situation and sometime the state
the prosecution will try to dress it up
a little bit with sort of collateral
Witnesses but these kind of thing I mean
if you just think about these kind of
things don't happen in public they
happen in private and so it's very often
almost always
he said she said and you know just
speaking personally most of the ones I
heard when when she said it was mostly
true I mean that would be if you know if
I were the FactFinder and most of the
time if the jury was a FactFinder it
probably was most of the time true but
it's not always true and it I think it's
uh we as a society have a really strong
interest in making sure that you know we
don't that that we don't end up
tarnishing an innocent person um as I as
I think I said on the floor you know we
it's always been our the the history of
Western democracy that it's better to
have 10 guilty people escape punishment
than have one innocent person be uh be
wrong wrongfully charged or wrongfully
convicted and I think that that that
same process has to be true in the
school setting so that's why I think
questions
yes thank you Mr
chairman yeah protective
orders uh that uh I had some uh
calls on this bill and that's one of the
things they were worried about was
protective orders and you know a lot of
girls that that uh that happens to you
know they leave I think they they come
up with with a statistic of like
39% that uh that they left how how do
you how would you how would that work in
this within this
bill the the protective the protective
the protective order and and enforcing
it I mean it's because most of these
kids come in you know from other states
or other other towns and uh that that
was one of the
questions you know they had concerns I'm
I'm not quite sure I know what you mean
by in other words if you mean by
protective order that how do we how does
the how does the person that's that's
the accuser how does the accuser be you
know protected from harassment or
something like that I mean
that's I no it's the other it'd be the
other way
around in other words the the girl goes
let's say she's from Massachusetts right
and he tries to follow her even though
there's a protective order on
oh sure well that I mean that's not
something I don't I don't that's not
something that in the school kind that's
not something that this bill addresses I
mean that would be the school doesn't
have any authority to issue a protective
order that would be something you'd have
to go to court for and so the the uh the
court could certainly issue a protective
order I mean I they might you know could
a school say don't go to this dormatory
or don't sure I think they probably
could do something like that but in
terms of a of a real protective order
that you know somebody could be punished
for violating go by by you know having
to be found in contempt of court you'd
that well sure yeah I don't that's not
how I understood I don't think that's
what he was saying suppose you have um a
faculty member who has been a who has
been accused of sexual assault right and
the police have issued issued a
restraining order that he can't go near
her but it's in reading this it sounds
like the school could have her come in
and face her accuser and the issue is
how do you protect if she has a
protective order from her from her um
the person who assaulted her this says
well you know you just come on in we
will just ignore the protective order I
think that's what he was getting yeah
well we you know I mean
that it would be hard to imagine that
the protective order would apply to that
I mean for example if a protective if a
protective order is issued in let's say
your example a protective order is
issued that protective order doesn't
mean that if the that if the if there's
a criminal charge or even a civil charge
against the accused the person accused
that the person who is who is the
accuser can say I don't have to go to
court because I have a protective order
and I'd I'd be in his presence think I'm
not sure that we're still on the same
page I think the the problem is
that let's just make it you know this
way right you have to stay away from me
because I'm accusing you of hurting me
right and so the police say you stay
away from me from here it sounds like
you you're being brought up in front of
the university to address this issue
right um and I have to come in and
testify I am not being protected from
you I am being in the same room with you
and that doesn't make me feel
comfortable what but well but the
problem with that is that's that's no
different than it is would be in a civil
proceeding or Court proceeding you if
you're the victim and you get a
protective order so that the Vic so that
the the accused has to stay away from
you that doesn't mean that when the case
comes to trial you don't have to go to
court you of course you have to go to
court and you have to you have to face
your accuser and that's I mean that's
that's like the very basis of our
justice system we don't allow we don't
have a system that says you can and kind
of make a claim against somebody and
then you never have to uh you never have
person just can't you do that remotely
now can you do it that's possible I
suppose that's possible I don't think
there would be I don't know that I mean
in in a criminal trial I don't think you
could do that I think that would be but
in some in a proceeding like this I
think that probably would be true I
think the the you know the a school
could say okay look we you know we're
going to um we're going to have a
hearing and the the accused is going to
be able to to uh confront the accuser
but it can be done remotely and I would
think that that would be that that would
make sense because the hearing officer
still going to be able to look at the
person and you know that kind of thing
so I think that probably would make
sense so thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking the questions I just want
to clarify my understanding because it's
my first term do I understand correctly
that the protective order would protect
you from contact in your normal life but
when you do go to hearings where you
know there may be cross questioning
right you expect those people to be
there and it's just something that we
need to require in order to get the
correct outcomes from those cases right
right no I mean that's exactly you don't
the the the I have
never understood I've never had anyone
even claim that a protective order means
that if you're the if you're the victim
or you're the person that accuses
someone of doing something wrong that
the protective order protects you from
not having to go to court and I think
the same thing would apply here it
wouldn't protect you from not having to
go to the hearing although I do agree
that you know and depending on the case
the it might very well make sense for
the hearings officer to say we're going
to do this remotely that that might very
well makes sense assuming you had video
and all
that uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh what
precipitated this why uh I got I got I
got quite a few calls on this like I
said sure and they feel comfortable with
what they're doing now in other words
the universities right and the community
colleges yeah yeah you know I'm I'm I'm
sure I and I don't mean to say this fous
I and I I I have the utmost respect for
both the university system and the
community colleges and I'm sure that
they do feel that they're doing it cor
you know and everything's fine what I
would ask you to consider is this you
know these these kinds of due process
cases due process issues have been going
on I mean at least since the 1970s or
maybe maybe the maybe the mid-60s
even in which in which nor courts have
said no no you can't you can't do this
the way you're doing it you've got to
have more fairness more process and the
argument that has always been made and I
mean you can read it in the New
Hampshire Supreme Court constitutions
you can read it in the United States
Supreme Court constition the argument
that has always been made by those who
don't want to have more procedural
fairness is everything's fine no problem
we're handling this just fine it's all
informal if you if you if you require
more process it's going to get more
confrontational that is always the
argument and I believe it's from from
their perspective it's made in good
faith but the but the problem is it's if
you afford greater due process
protection that doesn't that that's a
good thing that means that you have you
can have more confidence in the fairness
of the outcome I mean given you know the
the the 10 things that you're talking
about uh notice of the charges Advanced
disclosure of witnesses and evidence the
presumption of innocence the privilege
against self-incrimination the right to
cross-examine um the right to have an
advocate all all of those
things it you know does it does it mean
that there'll be more more
process sure will it take a little
longer sure um but I mean that's that's
what our system is designed to do to
make sure that we arrive at the right
result not the convenient
answer thank you Mr chair I'm just
looking for a little bit of data point
to Anchor this discussion I'm wondering
you know the expense that I'm looking at
the fiscal note it's quite Hefty so I'm
wondering you know what in the past
say 5 10 academic years how many of
these
adverse um action cases like I think you
said before or disciplinary hearings
right have there been and uh you know
maybe we could measure that against the
you know the request for the fiscal no
yeah yeah I mean in terms of you know
can I give you numbers for New Hampshire
I can't I mean I can what I can say is
that from around the country I think we
have seen you know it's been it's been
pretty well publicized in various places
of examples of
situations where you know the the for
lack of a better term the cancel culture
has has uh has had sway um and I you
know that's um that I think we should
not that is not a good thing that is
really not a good you know just not a
good
thing and are you aware of any um
significant
requests from members of the student
body or even professional staffs on
these campuses that believe this
addition is important
the I mean there's particular
individuals who say I was a victim of in
I can't say I Happ any in New Hampshire
but you know I again I go back
to I'm not sure that you can trust the
fact that we haven't seen that to mean
that it hasn't occurred because as I say
before you know if you're let's say
you're the student that was found to
have assaulted someone in a pro in a
process that that maybe the student
thinks well this wasn't really such a
fair process but you've got you've now
been been found to have committed this
assault are you going to you know maybe
maybe you're going to be very brave and
say yep I don't want you know I this was
wrong I want I I want changes to be made
or maybe you're going to say Jesus you
know I don't want anybody to know about
this um I'm embarrassed by it I'm not
selling a soul and so I you know I don't
know I I I I don't think that that's
necessarily a very good indication of
not thank you actually um my colleague's
question kind of helped me answer a
question I was going to ask Mickey in
regards to how in God's name did you
come up with a fiscal note and it seems
to me that the fiscal note kind of
answers the number of cases where these
rights have not been afforded because
that to me is the estimate of the
resources that we would need to spend to
comply and therefore the university
itself is telling us that we have a lot
of these hearings where as of now all
those rights are not afforded and
therefore this is why it's rather
expensive to fix it so to me the proof
is in the pudding if the fiscal note is
big is because there are a lot of these
proceedings happening that you know to
me if we are putting people in those
situations and have such serious
accusations look this is not about small
things right most of these they never
get to the point where you get a formal
hearing if the university I I spoke you
know I I I speak with the universities a
lot and if by any chance I misrepresent
something that was said to me please
correct me we have University
representatives in the room but my
understanding is that most our
situations are
solved you know informally as inde you
did something wrong you realize it yeah
you know and we move on it's when they
get
contested that the expenses start
accumulating and those are the cases
where I think we do have a duty to
protect those rights for everybody the
rights of the victim the rights of the
accused the rights of everybody else on
the campus they are all meaningful and
we don't lose them when we go there so I
think that this is not as much a
question as a comment and I apologize
for not making that clear from the
beginning ital eliminates my question on
why the note is so big it's because
there is a lot of this stuff happening
that we got to do it right thank you if
I could just make one if I could just
add one comment to that to
the I agree with what exactly with what
you said but I would I would just point
out one other thing to the extent that
the argument is made by the university
system and the community college system
that you know their processes now really
are fair really are basically Fair
then I would suggest to you remember
this bill does not it says if the
nothing in in this bill prohibits in
fact it specifically says if they have
equivalent
procedures they can continue to use
those procedures so if their procedures
really are basically the same and the
only thing I remember hearing when this
was before the education committee the
only one point that was raised was that
there was um maybe some time limits
weren't exactly the same as exist in in
some of their internal procedures well
if that's the issue if the if the only
question is you know you need more time
or less time then change this bill by
all means change the bill to you know to
make the time limits comply I'm not the
that if it's 10 days as opposed to 14
days or seven days as opposed to four
that's not to me that's not a huge a
huge issue I guess what I'm saying is
it's if the process is that the
university system and the community
college system is using right now is
really a basically Fair one then it's
not very much different than what's in
here and there won't be much expense on
the other hand if it turn if it really
is considerably different than this then
maybe there will be more expense and
fairness thank you Mr chair thank you
for I don't know if it's a question or
comments I'm going to make I sat in on
the education committee I've been
subbing in that committee lately um I
was there um I was there for the
executing of this bill and I voted
against it um I feel very uncomfortable
with this bill we have our University
Systems have done a good job both at the
community college level and higher
education I've received lots of comments
from lots of people who are very
concerned about this bill I can't
possibly vote for it and and I just I
have to commend the university system in
the community colleges for the work that
they've done they have a process and a
system that works well and you can't
present any data to us that says
otherwise I just feel very uncomfortable
you
thank you uh my name is Chad pintel I'm
the general councel of the University
system of New Hampshire I have some
colleagues here who work in uh student
discipline and in contract enforcement
um thank you for for hearing us out on
this um I want to make a couple of
points um about why the university
system even after this bill has been
amended somewhat remains concerned by it
um the the first is that it is unclear
how this bill interacts with the
existing obligations that the university
system already has under Federal
Constitution federal law and our
Collective barging agreements um I'll
give an example um and the details of
all this change depending on what group
you're talking about and what whichever
institutions you're talking about but if
a faculty member were to be terminated
at the University of New Hampshire now
um setting aside all of the informal and
sort of paperwork laying around it's
when actually gets time to move into the
formal process where they go is before
essentially uh Comm of their peers that
go to a faculty committee who hears the
information and weighs in on whether or
not they think the faculty member ought
to be determinated because the faculty
we have shared governance with them and
that is part of their role um what
taking that into account the
administration makes a decision and then
under the collective Bing agreement that
is grievable that decision and that goes
all the way through um if it goes all
the way arbitration in front of a
neutral
arbitrator so that first hearing
may not reach all of these 10 points
because it's not designed to it's
designed to get input from one of our
shared governance Partners
um I I think raises the possibility that
if we're going to terminate a faculty
member at UNH under the current
Collective barging agreement we would
have to have that hearing in front of
the faculty committee this hearing and
then it could be grieved and go all the
way through arbitration um that is a
tremendous administrative burden to
engage in a single employment action uh
and I encourage my my colleagues to jump
up and seize me by the back of my my
jacket if I've gotten that wrong um
that's just one example another example
of of how this would interact in a
challenging way with um our federal law
obligations is um to the extent that
there's a criminal law matter involved
we're we're meant to wait until the
criminal proceedings are over before we
start our
own we have obligations under federal
civil rights law though that if the
matter involved involves sexual violence
sexual harassment racial discrimination
to take immediate action to rectify it
um the bill suggested that immediate
action could be some kind of interim
suspension interim action but the
federal courts in the first circuit um
have made it pretty clear that that
long-term interim actions are not
permissible under the Federal
Constitution so we might be in a place
where the Federal Constitution says we
have the federal law says we have to act
the Federal Constitution says it can't
be an interim action and state law says
we can't do a final action while we're
waiting around for the criminal
proceedings to end um we're stuck in a
bit of a bind there and so again this a
this all a long way of saying where
there are these points where it's
unclear how it fits together where there
is at least a risk of a significantly
increased administrative burden to the
system and there doesn't seem to be a
current problem in our state in this
regard um the downsides don't seem to be
worth the added value from the
University Systems perspective um my
colleagues may have more additional
information provide but I'll pause here
if folks have questions I'll do my best
to answer them if I have
it I'm just wondering um if you could
speak on behalf of your systems
disciplinary action data
um could you give us a rough rough
estimate um in any time frame that you
would like to select of how many
disciplinary
hearings are undertaken by the system
and you know maybe you could speak to
the range of disciplinary hearings is it
um anything from alcohol violations to
sexual assaults or academic cheating
maybe you could speak to that as well um
I I think if if we have our un D of
students here I may actually defer to
him on that because he would be closer
to that data um the point I would pick
out of your question though is while a
lot of discussion we've had already has
been around sexual assault sexual
violence issues this bill is not limited
to that it's it's anything that rises to
a certain level of and so it's the again
from an administrative burden
perspective the breadth of it is
slightly bigger than I think we've been
maybe talking about captur in this
Potato
is ah that sounds better so Michael
Blackman Dena students at the University
of New Hampshire where I've been for
about three years now so I just want to
say from the beginning that we overall
support the spirit of the bill that we
believe due process protections are
critical for any student that is at risk
for being sanctioned through our conduct
process proc any student that goes
through the conduct process at the
University of New Hampshire is afforded
substantial due process protections that
are clearly defined in our student
rights rules and responsibilities
handbook and our code of conduct and we
believe these are necessary due process
protections to protect the property
rights of these students who have paid
for their education and should have
access to it without being deprived
without a
process the key thing to keep in mind is
that the due process protections we
afford to students are based on the
potential severity of the sanction so
for an underage student that is caught
drinking at a
party that student meets with a trained
staff member and has due process
protections including the right to
respond meaningfully the right to be
provided notice and the right to an
impartial decision
maker that student is likely going to
get a warning and an educational
sanction as a result of that underage
drinking violation we do not bring every
single student that was in that party in
for cross-examination it is not a good
use of those students time it is not a
good use of the respondents time and
it's not a necessary step to protect
someone from getting something like a
warning and an educational sanction to
give some data to this as was asked last
year we had about 3,000 cases go through
the conduct system at the University of
New Hampshire only about 80 of those
cases resulted in a hearing with due
process protections that more closely
align with what's outlined in the this
bill and those are cases where a student
was at risk for being suspended from the
University suspended from housing
removed from the University or removed
from housing we afford much more
substantial due process Protections in
those cases and they represent about a
fraction of what we deal with on a
day-to-day basis so to speak
specifically about the fiscal note and
the financial implications one thing
that was appreciated in the amendment is
that the bar raised for when this would
apply for students is suspensions and
above which is very helpful we still
believe that we would require additional
staff because the way that the bill is
written uh it still broadens when we
need to have hearings for student
organizations again for even very
lowlevel violations it's also not clear
that this bill doesn't apply to academic
suspensions which is not handled through
a hearing process when a student is
suspended for a very low
GPA um but the real added con C here is
as Chad spoke to the the cost of
Defending ourselves against many
lawsuits which we believe we would incur
based on the Amendments addition of us
needing to wait for criminal processes
to be done before taking any action
against a student so I would our
director of community standards can
correct me if I'm wrong about this but
if you think about those 80 hearings I
describ before I would estimate at least
2third of them they were criminal
charges at Play these are processes that
can take months or years to resolve and
we are obligated by the federal
government to move quickly through our
processes to safeguard the community an
interim restriction is actually
antithetical to the due process rights
in the bill because what we're doing is
we're removing a student from their
Education Without a process we're
interim suspending them without
affording them the full process that has
also been slapped down in courts within
this circuit as as a as a method that we
cannot employ we cannot interim suspend
students for years while we wait for a
criminal justice process to finish so
our estimate for the cost is based on
the fact that many individuals that go
through these hearings would be able to
successfully sue us because it is in
conflict with the expectations outlined
by sub-regulatory guidance from the
Department of Education and also case
law that suggests that we do have an
obligation to quickly protect our
community when there is potential for
violence or
harm I'll pause there and take questions
thank you Mr chair I had one quick
question um earlier but I didn't want to
interrupt your testimony you were
talking about the um scenario where a u
underage drinking may u happen and uh
that in that situation you don't feel
the need to uh you know cross-examine
other students and so on and so forth as
far as I understand this bill says they
can cross-examine your accusers you know
or Witnesses brought I mean unless the
University uses those people as you know
they they brought the complaint or they
are
witnesses I'm I'm not sure what you
meant because the only people I can
think of that would need to be
cross-examined are people who either
make the accusation or testify that that
happened sure why would you feel that
that's not necessary to cross-examine
them when they are bringing you evidence
that's used that now the accused person
would not be able to question sure I I
would say two things the first is that
the people that I'm referring to when
we're talking about Witnesses if there
was underage drinking at a party that
party could have 20 30 40 students
present the accused could actually be a
member of our University Police
Department or the Durham Police
Department um so we're talking about
substantial amounts of students that
witness the case and also staff members
raas Hall directors police officers that
were bringing forth the case and all of
that in a situation where the sanction
is likely going to be a warning and for
students as has been asked at this group
who is complaining about this I would
say that many of our students believe
that an appropriate resolution to the
potential of getting a warning for an
underage drinking violation when a
19-year-old is caught with a beer is to
have notice of what they're accused of a
meaningful opportunity to respond and an
impartial decision maker making that
decision that they would not need to
bring their friends in who are at the
party to be cross-examined that the
police officers would need to be
cross-examined and that's just one
example of a due process protection that
we usually we reserve for those
situations where student is at risk for
significant deprivation of their
education suspensions suspensions from
housing dismissals removals from housing
not the
2,920 cases that we resolve through
conduct conferences with a trained staff
member a quick follow-up question sorry
before the question just a quick comment
yeah while I'm not going to talk about
the specifics I'm aware of at least one
case in which somebody was incorrectly
accused of drinking and in this process
they probably would have gotten a
warning even though they didn't do
anything but since I'm not able to you
know discuss a situation in particular
I'll just say that such situations have
been known to occur everywhere and I
would feel that before you warn somebody
for having some done something wrong you
should be reasonably sure that they
really did something wrong this being
said again just a comment it's my
opinion the question is um actually I
managed to forget my question I
apologize I took myself out of it I I
the floor sorry may I respond by what
means I I would just say that it is far
from the the purpose of the conduct
process and the student having a
meaningful opportunity to respond is to
reassure students that these processes
are far from decided before they get
that opportunity so um when I say that a
warning is a potential sanction that's
what I mean it's a potential sanction
it's far from cited and our director of
community standards could speak more to
this but we do not have a 100%
responsibility rate students go to these
meetings they share their side of the
story and many of these students are
found not responsible I can't speak to
your specific case obviously but these
meeting sure thank you
all swear to God I'm going to start
though may I just make one other comment
I I think it's important with regard to
what the last witness said I I I think I
what much of what he said actually
supports the view that this bill is a
good idea because what he really is
saying and I'm I'm sure it's right that
you know 90% in the in the criminal
justice system 95% of cases don't go to
trial they result they result in a in a
negotiated plea disposition that's I'm
sure that in this in the college
disciplinary process that's true too I I
have no doubt that many many the vast
majority of cases where there are sort
of some minor the the drinking situation
or somebody being boisterous those those
are not going to end up in a hearing
they're going to resolve because the the
the university official is going to say
look here's the evidence that we're that
we're going to we're going to pursue
we're going to offer against you if you
go to a hearing and the person is going
to say you know yeah I was drunk that
night and I don't you know I don't want
to drag this out and and have a and have
a hearing and it's going to resolve but
this and and and in that case just as in
the plea bargain in a criminal case
there will be no trial there will be
there will be no hearing and
cross-examination and all
that but this is important because there
will be some cases in which in which
people will say I didn't do it and so
you know whether it's drinking or sexual
assault or whatever and I want to have
my day in court or my day of a hearing
in the in the disciplinary process and
so it's those few cases that where the
rights here are particularly important
most of them they will you know they
won't they won't go to the hearing
there'll be no hearing it'll be resolved
thank good afternoon I'm Shannon Reed
representing the community college
system of New Hampshire um there's
really not much additive that I can say
um to expand on what's been said by U
previous speakers and I say I'm
particularly to follow the former Chief
Justice on some of these broad matters
but I would say that we certainly share
the concerns of of our colleagues at the
University system but but I would also
say that um well two things one it seems
that folks are are concerned or worried
that that there would not be due process
rights without this bill and and I can
assure you that that's not that's not
the case we have robust and
comprehensive policies that that work
well for us and Serv us well as an
educational institution we are not um
we're not courts these are employment
matters there student organization and
disciplinary matters it's it's really a
different level of um a different level
of of severity but but the second thing
I just want to say is we did submit
fiscal impact statements and if you are
considering passing this bill or moving
it Forward I hope that you will also
consider the fiscal impact on our
organizations and include an
appropriation at least to help us adjust
to whatever new expectations this bill
would would create new requirements need
for new training need for in our case
and and I believe I heard the
University's case for new Personnel um
so I I would say that if you
do decide to move this forward I I hope
that you will support it with funding
that will help us not have to make Cuts
elsewhere in order to accommodate there
new requirements of this
Bill thank
you thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um M re I'm sure this
will be an easy
response um are you aware um and is it
true that um if a student or employee of
the system is unfairly disciplined and
separated from the
institution because of a alleged
violation of their due process is it
isn't it true that they can proceed to
litigation using the court system to to
um resolve that
grievance I believe that's the case
thank
you thank you got turn my mic on would
you like to
comment no oh okay cuz you were kind of
I thought you were jumping out of your
chair
though anyone else like to
comment yeah if I may just again suggest
that um discussing policy is fun and
important but at the end of the day you
know we're here to look at the money and
um at this point in time all we have on
the financial on the fiscal note is the
estimate uh you know provided and
prepared by the staff and everybody's
done their best I think that given the
importance of such rights I uh you know
I agree that we have to pay for the
mandates that we place on our public
institutions of Higher Learning so um I
can assure everybody that uh you know I
will do everything I can to make sure
obviously the funds are available
because you got to be able to do the job
you can we have the flexibility of
making this um take place in the next
budget like making the effective date
later so that we we are discussing this
at the same time we're discussing their
you so let me ask you just for clarity I
I the effective date on on this was July
1 of
2025 so automatically goes to the next
budget
right so this would be cons there's no
money right but there could be by the
time
yes
y so is your is your recommendation then
to move this forward as it is unfunded
and then pick it up in the budget or
is that your is that a
motion
okay do we have the
second second U just two quick comments
um it seems to me in a situation like
this the fiscal note is really kind of
hypothetical guessing at what might
happen not what is happening now and so
I don't think we have a good sense of
what that miscal note represents and the
other thing I have to say after
listening to representative Lynn speak
the second time it sounds to me like he
agrees with Mr Blackman which would make
the
unnecessary well there was a certain
element there because if you read these
it looks like
steps every every infraction gets every
step and I think uh representative Lyn's
comments was that's not the case only
the steps that apply and you can you can
plead you can plead out a deal without
that's HED can stop it essentially at
any time by saying okay you know I don't
want to contest any further I'll accept
whatever discipline whatever so we're
only talking about cases where the the
accuse says no I didn't do it and I'm
I'm gonna we're going to have a fight on
our hands right or or cases where the
accuse where where the system says we
want expell you and the student says
wait a minute I you know maybe I did do
something wrong but you know a 3we
suspension
is muchi if you're you're throw me out
then I want to hear
are okay any other comment yes thanks I
just like to take a moment to talk about
um the financial implications of
attempting to establish a secondary
pseudo judicial process through the
education you know our educational
institutions that would be running in
parallel to an actual judicial process
of the state you know it seems to me
that the state of New Hampshire's
taxpayers have already paid for one
court system and that a second court
system is not necessary and that I think
that that would be a large dra drag on
you know the Public's use of funds so I
can't support this spill at all I think
that this is um I think that the
intention is well-meaning but that I
think you know that the big ask of using
these funds to create a second parallel
judicial system is inappropriate is an
inappropriate use of funds I can't
support
it okay I think in this case we'll have
we'll ask the clerk to call a
rooll sorry thank you Mr chair the
motion is OTP
um representative amoric yes represent
representative Petri yes representative
Bean yes myself yes Representative buo
no representative Heath representative
Murray no representative hen Phillips no
representative Wier thank you the motion
to4 okay thank
you since we are past the start time we
will move now into
uh House Bill
1330 may I be excuse for just one minut
establishing an emergency medical
panel is there anyone here that would
please good afternoon Mr chairman and
committee my name is Mark PR Hillsboro
15 I brought forth this bill um for a
couple of reasons um full disclosure I'm
a firefighter EMT so I've seen how the
old process works and we needed to
update it and it's been updated to uh
resemble all the other boards that are
in like oplc and things like that
originally one person was making the
determination on whether somebody was
going to be uh suspended license revoked
or any things like that and there's
actually two pieces to to this bill so
that first piece is one person was
making that
decision and there was no time
constraints on how long they could take
to make that decision and here you have
somebody whose
livelihood is pending for a long time
time right
so the case that kind of brought this to
me is someone had to make a life in
death
decision somebody questioned it it went
on for over 11 months almost a year with
very little information coming back to
her on how this was
progressing what was going on so every
day she woke up not knowing
so in in my bill I put that they have 90
days to come
up and at least send this person an
update of why it's taken longer than 90
days and give an update on the case and
then every 30 days following
that we are creating a three member
panel uh taking it away from the one
person the commissioner of
safety the other piece of that is that
they have a web page that list everyone
who's been
disciplined uh and you were going to
stay on that list
forever I actually had a a close
personal friend who was on that list who
passed
away the family asked me to reach out
and get the name removed and I was told
nope we can't do that because there's
nothing in law that allows us to do that
I said it's not like she's coming back
for her
job right and they said no can't do it I
said well I'm going to go fix that and
as I started to try and fix that problem
I looked at the bigger problem and
figured out I might as well try and
bring this system up to date with what
the state is doing for the rest of the
boards and that's if you have questions
I'm happy to try and answer them
questions
yes could you describe under current the
current process um who is making those
decisions Commissioner of safety so the
director of
EMS will recommend to the commissioner
and he can either take that
recommendation or make it on his own
and not to be derogatory but here you
have a police
officer making EMS
decisions which didn't make sense to
me
okay question thank you Mr chair I do
have a question in the in that office of
Professional Standards is there just one
person that that's regulating all the
different professions no not not how I
know it each each one has their own
little board I guess they still have
them and and they have their own
procedures for discipline but as far as
I know they all have a minimum of three
on their disciplinary board thank
you
question thank you can you explain about
the
um seven years from the disciplinary
date um that you would like to have the
name removed um I guess two questions of
you know the most basic one is like why
um but
also aren't there a range of reasons why
you would be on the list some more minor
than others and if there is a major one
why would you want that removed after
seven years so you get removed from the
web page but it goes into your file and
stays there forever so it's not like
that infraction disappears it's just
more out of the public view so if you
were going to hire
somebody you would approach the state
and said hey what's in their file and
the state would let you know but it's
just makes it a little bit and that's
what all the other boards and oplc do as
well so I'm just trying to align it with
with
every yeah I guess you I sort of
answered it when you said to align it
with the other boards but when you're
looking at elements of safety um I sort
of feel an obligation that the public
maybe it's more important for the public
to be able to know who's on that list as
opposed to any of the other B LIC so the
phys board the nursing board the Dental
Board all those people are out in seven
you another question yes thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for taking my
question representative um I see in the
fiscal note it talks about the
department stating that it would need to
hire a part-time administrator one to
administer the ma to manage the work of
the legislation um and that it would
start November 1st 2024 so maybe
potentially later this year um do you
have any comments about you know I'm not
sure why they have to hire somebody
because there's not that that many
infractions that happen they are far and
few between and I know the uh director
has the ability to uh issue letters of
concern which are like a warning and
they use those quite a bit
so there's really no Administration with
that but to suspend and revoke um
they're already do they already have an
investigator and a part-time
investigator that will uh present the
facts to the to the board so I'm kind of
missing where the extra Administration
is follow yeah I'm looking at the
allocation the 23, 350 and um just my
guess is that this is probably a
part-time like a FTE essentially so
maybe they're just looking for a little
you does this uh board charge dues or
fees or anything is there does it have a
funding mechanism so no so there are
three other boards that are associated
with EMS there's a protocol board
there's a medical Direction board and
for the life of me I can't remember the
third that are already in place that
work with the EMS bureau and we're
taking one member from each of
those uh as an additional duty to to
what they do now th do those boards have
administrative support I believe so okay
because I this may be
unnecessary the funding other
motion yep like to move to
OTP okay and seconded by representative
petre
all those in favor raise your
hand okay nobody it's unanimous thank
you after the last bill I was kind of
nervous I just want to I want to put
there all right where are
we uh
representative
30 seconds
1 okay we'll move on then to House Bill
check there's a new what I'm
sorry
oh
see yeah this it listed a part-time
administrator yeah for 24 to
yeah
and this was this was passed by the
bill anybody on the committee have
motion okay representative pet mov OTP
second
representative all those in favor raise
your
unanimous now that we've caught up with
TR sure take a break now and everybody's
gone our next one's at 2:15 and I cannot
chase them in the hallway because they
okay
adequate education here we
[Music]
go
yeah I've got one thank
you
lot of gray matter to be reading here
sleep
day here's more here's more copies if
you need them oh this
is
7 oh look at got a fancy don't you get a
education we don't get a p no I see your
your we're swapped here all right oh
now
being I'm expecting that thank 35 we
1583 uh just get as a little bit of an
update uh
1583 uh has a is carrying a a a c cost
of about $100 million give or take is
that a little bit less per year yeah 90
million 8 I mean yes as it currently
stands what I what you've received is I
I uh propose a an
amendment and it was kind of interesting
I served on a special Committee of uh
adequacy and it was like we were talk I
was in Lily put because some people
wanted to based on output and some
people want to based on input so it was
kind of an interesting interesting
dialogue to see but as an outsider I can
look at well I'll give you a third
one the Judgment from the
conal uh judge was the adequacy should
be
$735
And1 per student so I'm starting
there how they got it I have no idea
we'll just have to say that it was
adjudicated and this this was the answer
so th this moves the adequacy from the
$4,100 in uh in the in the bill to the
$7,000 number let me give you the
overview of the of the amendment there's
three parts to this
amendment uh the first part
is redefining what was the word that we
use this recar recharacterizing that's
it what we're going to what we have
right now is the state spend for
education is over $3
million combined state and
local what the first section does is it
recharacterized some of the local
education tax into
swep so swept goes up local taxes go
down so the taxpayer is paying the same
amount of money we basically just said
okay this portion of your locally
collected education tax is now going to
be called
swep so you'll see that the the total
swep is now
773 million instead of the 300 whatever
363 so now it's 733
now it's page one it's in the amendment
it's in the amendment that I passed
one l 10
11 l 10 11
11 all right page two largely speaks to
a a c
a ceiling on local appro
appropriation the reason for this is if
we are going to increase the
swep or the
adequacy we don't want then also have
the local taxing Authority in education
saying well we we're going to bump it
back up and charge everything we were
because now we got we got the same money
the same taxpayer getting having a bump
up so what this does it says you can
increase based on cost of living or an
if your legislative body by a two-thirds
vote wants to increase your uh your your
budget but other than that it only it's
approximately okay that's the that's
page
two and P and by the way I'm not looking
to vote on this
today all right the the intention here
is to pass it out give you time to
digest and we'll do this at another time
thank you Mr
chair Okay the third page is basically
the swept portion for the towns that
have excess
swept and it was the brand decision that
says you can't do it it was a conval
decision that says you can't you can't
keep it it's got to go back to the state
because it's called Statewide education
property tax so any excess in my town is
one of them goes back to the goes back
to the state that's what page three is
thank
pieces does anybody have
any
questions so this basically does away
was swept entirely no no no no no no
okay it it it it doubles swept basically
yeah but it goes to the state that
doesn't stay in the
municipality yes excess the excess goes
to the state and set of states with the
municipality
yes thank you Mr chair so um first
obviously as representing wiam which uh
will uh suffer a significant financial
burden as a result of that Court
decision I understand that there is not
much what we can what we we can do about
it but let's just say that U it will be
hard to to explain that one home but uh
my question is when we um control the
growth of the budget how do we account
for communities where the population is
increasing or decreasing because you
know one of the concerns in wind is that
we are one of the few towns that keeps
increasing in population so we are under
quite a bit of pressure and if we would
be tied to no if you read it I did not
read P you haven't had a chance yet if
your population is increasing you can
increase your budget good thank
you
yes thank you Mr chair um now I'm
confused we have your Amendment yes and
we had
1583 but passed on the floor right what
does this do to that it it's an
addition so all of all of all of this
stays all all of it stays and this is
you now we have a lot of
information about what stays if you want
to get into that now we can do it now
and we can pass it out now and then
discuss it when we reconvene on this why
don't you mark why who Mickey who's got
something they want to pass out let's go
ahead Mr chair I think we'd be great if
people could hear what would happen
during the subcommittee because think we
work and I know many of us followed
along U while the subcommittee was
meeting but not everybody heard every
recap
well I
I I kind of preempted the meeting quite
honestly that's what I'm saying there
was all a whole bunch of logic for
outputs and a whole bunch of logic for
inputs and I said well let's take the
judge's input start there okay and can I
justify this number absolutely not all I
know is that's what the judge said yeah
get
top
time am I correct this is this is pre
pre
Amendment the these are for House Bill
1583 as it passed the house not the Emer
Amendment
right so so everybody check your
town okay let's get
down
51 I don't know I I got to study this on
tiny
would mark would you like to make any
comments yeah no if you have any
questions um I'll try to see if I can
help if we have any questions don't
don't put on
question you have any um so so Mickey
put together Mickey put together these
um these documents um so he can speak to
them in more detail but um yes uh as it
amended the house floor and came over to
this committee there was fiscal capacity
disparity Aid which for fiscal year 24
is around $39 million and uh relief Aid
which um in in Mickey spreadsheets is
around $22 million um so that's the $61
million increase remember relief Aid is
targeting communities that have high fnr
percentages um and fiscal capacity to
disparity Aid is based on the students
and property so if you have low property
values relative to how much students you
have um you get more fiscal capacity to
disparity Aid so um that was the work of
the subcommittee as representative emmer
talked about um and then got introduced
into 1583 and passed the house floor um
so that was the bill as you received it
and Mickey has also he's done fiscal
year 25 26 27 and he's done a little bit
of forecasting on the impacts of um of
these programs going forward um so how
the the law uh the bill as amended would
potentially adjust um and he had to make
some difficult assumptions assumptions
we typically don't make which is growth
in property value because it's been so
substantial so I think Mickey uh we
looked at some data and 7% seemed good
um we have no clue if property values
will go by 7% next year but um kind had
he kind of had to plug a number in there
so I think that's a fair number um so
you'll see those reflected in that
estimate and essentially as property
value grows at a rate of 7% you would
expect fiscal capacity to disparity Aid
to decrease faster than uh uh it would
just decrease because property values
would grow faster than the adjustment
factors because the adjustment factor in
the bill is 2% um so that's you're
seeing you're actually seeing a decline
in funding uh and some of that's based
on student enrollment declines well
actually you're not seeing a decline
you're seeing uh it stay kind of flat
and some of that's because of student
enrollment declines that Mickey uh put
into his assumption but also um growth
and property values that Mickey put in
his assumptions okay and I I have one
more detail of what my Amendment does is
million in in my bill it will go closer
to $91 million excess swept so more
swept 91
million
yes um I'm not I don't think it's just
me but I'm feeling a little overwhelmed
the your your amendment is very
different from the bill and so I'm um
would either like to hear um if
education has had a chance or maybe Mark
Mr Mel would know as well um you gave an
overview of the changes um but I need
someone to help me knit the two together
to understand what the differences are
and what the impacts of those
differences are and you know I'm just a
now
1583 I I can help out there uh so so 15
1583 as that amended is is very similar
to what you've been doing as a as a body
for a while now is you're you're
focusing on targeting Aid to communities
that need it and so physical capacity
disparity a targets communities that
have low property values relief Aid
targets it so that is uh um you know 60
million in targeted a that's what the
bill you received what representative
Em's uh Amendment does is it's dressing
the conval order and the Rand order so
the conval order came out February 20th
and it said immediately this is a
suprior court order immediately you need
to start paying
$735 in one penny in base adequacy Aid
um So currently that is an order that is
uh uh has not been stayed um the state
tried uh made a motion to stay the
motion to stay was uh denied uh this um
the doj is going to appeal to the
Supreme Court um to see what happens
there um we have not heard from the
Supreme Court I believe they've filed
their motion already um so what
representative em done uh amendment is
doing is addressing that requirement
that base Aid shall be 3,5 uh 3
7,356 one cent in one cense and um how
does that pertain to um disparity Aid
and it's on independent uh go away I
mean I need I'd like to know what's the
impact that has on these other things
stays exactly the same except for the
swept but won't these numbers change if
we're bringing up the 7,000 won't the
numbers on these things change and so
that's I'm kind of where I'm going is to
see what the impact
is so you don't have you don't have you
don't have uh the latest Amendment you
don't have that town by town in front of
you you don't have the um the bottom
line figures in front of you uh so so
raising base a up to 7,000 that does not
touch any other component of the formula
that doesn't touch physical capacity
extraordinary needs hold harmless um
well actually for fiscal year 25 it does
reduce the hold harmless um that's a
technical issue but uh it's uh uh not
not not impacting the additional Aid
programs uh for the most part then
there's the swept increase the swept
increase is currently 363 million in law
um this amendment brings it to 773
million um and then has it uh
essentially float going forward and
likely will land around that $773
million um in the fiscal years Beyond
fiscal year 25 so the way a swept
increase works is uh so increasing your
base adequacy Aid if you increased your
base adequacy a from 4,100 to 7,000 and
you increase your swept it really
depends on what percentage of the state
students do you have and what percentage
of the state's property do you have so
if you're kind of one to one if you had
a growth in base Aid and a growth in
swept it wouldn't really change much for
you um you would still get the same
state cash check you would normally get
um that's not how works for every single
Community um for some people their
growth in swept is going to be a lot
larger than their gross in Bas Aid um
and for some communities their growth in
Bas a is going to grow a lot quicker
than they're swept so it is going to
that is going to change the formula of
course um and then of course the excess
swept component um some uh some
communities more communities as you
increase as you increase base Aid under
current swept excess swept goes from 29
million down to 12 million uh base Aid
to the conv Val order but as you
increase XS we to you know 773 million
even as you increase um base Aid uh to
7, uh 356 EXs swept is now um estimated
Amendment question I can't imagine
question I'm not sure how to ask um so
how do we get to
91 million excess
web uh
so the
scenario just to back up a little bit
the conval order came down the conv Val
order came down and the Rand order came
down and so if you don't touch
swept uh the state would need to find
400 $400 million to satisfy conal you
could find $400 Million by finding
Revenue $400 million you could find $400
Million by cutting all the
non-constitutional parts of the formula
that would heard a lot of the targeted
communities the other option you could
do is increase swept so increasing swept
to make it so you can afford um without
you know spending $400 million in new
Revenue um is kind of where if you like
if you depends on how much money you
have but if you don't have $400 million
increasing swept is a way to make
adequacy more
affordable so as a taxpayer M on my tax
bill yep I have that those little things
that say what I o what will I what will
it say so you're swept equalized rate
under this uh
formula um this is equalized so it's not
not necessarily what you might see on
your tax bill but it's going to more
than double so it's about a122 on an
equalized basis and it's going to go to
around a
$259 so you'll see your swept rate
increase which means you as a taxpayer
going to pay your swep taxes and that
those swep taxes um if you're not an
excess swep town 100% of those swep
taxes that you just paid to your tax
collector will go to your school
district so for some communities that's
what's going to happen but your but your
education tax line goes down okay
because the overall revenue is f is has
a cap on it
so the 7,3 the base the increase in the
base
7.3
um
that will
come part of that will already be just
like it is now yeah yeah okay got it and
some of that some of that is funded
through yeah so for like Manchester
Manchester swept will increase as their
base increases now where Manchester
shakes out as far as they have a lot of
students so they're going to be getting
a lot of base eight increase but they're
also have a lot of property so a lot of
swept
increase Mr chair just again to uh
better understand this on First Site um
a town like Windham which obviously will
become an excess swept Community right
our assuming our education budget stays
the same because we will have a larger
portion of swept but instead of
everything coming back to the town part
of it will stay with the state that
would mean that net our overall tax bill
has to increase if we keep the school
school budget exactly the same because
we would have to make up for the swept
we are sending to the state by through a
smaller decrease in my local education
tax do I understand this your
understanding is correct except your
understanding of Windam I think is might
be incorrect Windam I I don't think it's
an excess yeah I would be happy to be
wrong that's a good but the concern
remains for any other Town that's excess
swept and we are increasing them I mean
obviously I care about my town but I
also care about every other Town that's
in this situation so you know swap the
name with another yeah you're you're
you're correct so if your if your school
budget is a million dollar and you have
500k in local property taxes 250k in
adequacy state cash 250k in swept if I
increase your swept double it so now you
have 500k in swept money coming in 250k
in adequacy cash then if you stay your
budget the same then your local taxes
would go from 500k down to 250k so
assuming you keep your school budget
flat and controlling for all of the
revenue sources that may or may not come
in so a lot of ifs there but um that's
how it would work now for the XS swep
Community um say the XS swep Community
doesn't get any adequacy cash and then
swept is doubled so for the EXs swept
Community say their budget is 1 million
say they're swept uh uh they're swept is
uh we say their swept is 500,000 and
their local education is 500,000 so they
have a million dollar budget they have
500k local 500k all swept retained but
now let's say they don't get to retain
that swept anymore they have to remit
some of that swept to the state um so um
actually this doesn't deal with doubling
swept it gets way more complicated but
say they say they didn't have to retain
that swept let's let let me suggest that
you simplify and assume nothing else
changes we all know that's not going to
be the case but to just isolate this
impact totally so in this community in
Windam if in a non-x swep community if
they control their if they keep their
District budget um flat basically every
swep dollar increase will turn into a
local a local dollar decrease but for
NEX swep Community they will pay more in
taxes because what would happen was uh
million dollar budget 500k local 500k
swept now if they didn't get to retain
all of their swept and they had to give
250 over to the state that's 250 they
taxpayers are not sending to their
school district therefore their school
district needs to increase their local
taxes by 250 to fund their budget as it
currently exists so therefore um they're
still paying the full swept amount which
was 500k but now 250k less is going to
their school so therefore so that that's
how it works for an excess SW community
and and assuming as a quick followup
very quick assuming totally
unrealistically that every town in the
state next year will have the same
education budget and this bill becomes
law seeing how sometimes we'll see
property tax increases I'm assuming that
if everybody kept their budget equal you
know unchange some towns will have to
see property tax decreases because they
get you know that money is going to the
state to be distributed to other towns
you're right so there's 90 million in
excess swept that now comes into the
state and then is allocated throughout
throughout the formula we should expect
if nothing else changes which again
unrealistic that that 90 million will be
reflected in property ta tax drops in
whatever communities are the receivers
of the additional yep but controlling
controlling for all those factors yes
assuming nothing changes at all just
you questions oh thank you Mr chairman
so um this excess swept that stays with
the state now wasn't that usually used
to be called donut towns that's the
concept commonly referred to as donut
towns y so I mean you as soon as you
bring that up you generate opposition to
the bill but there's one other thing
though that if you're in a town that's
doing a revalu real estate
revaluation and they come in and all the
residential values have gone up three or
four times what happens to them that
that's a great question so uh there's
two different property values there's
your assessed value that you keep that
your community uh it's your Town's value
of your property and then there's the
state's value of your property and so
what the state does is they collect all
of the assessment data that each Town
assessor sends in and they do something
called equalizing it so they look at
your property your town assessor and
they go is this town assessor not
assessing very often is this town not
keeping up with market value and for the
equalized version of your property
they'll give it a boost they sure did so
so so they'll say this property is a lot
more a lot more valuable than say your
town has reported it um so for towns
that are really slow with assessing the
state will the state will talk about the
equalized value of that property trying
to bring it up to market value is going
to be much higher so that's what what
makes the tax Fair because everyone's on
a Level Playing Field in a sense that um
uh the property values have been you've
controlled for different assessing
practices within different towns which
absolutely do
exist until you equalize it yeah wow
thank
you other questions
yes just I want to put a concern out
there um I think we were on the floor we
passed two bills that we were very
excited about I think both sides
um this amendment is going to cause some
angst I just it's I it's in the room
already uh would it be better to have
this be a
separate
something too late unless we uh put it
on another bill it's just what I'm what
I'm afraid of is I don't want to see
this go down because of this is my
concern that I mean I hear everybody's
like
tents you know I'm all for the swept um
and I think I live in Manchester I mean
we have Kino we we spend lots people
spend lots of money in Manchester and we
don't get to keep it it goes up into
rooming meals it goes up whatever
wherever it goes to everybody else I get
it um and that's what swep was meant to
do um but I don't know there are do we
feel comfortable and I'd have to ask
Rick and Dave how they feel about it do
we feel comfortable in putting this
amendment on the floor when the first
thing that they're going to do the same
thing that I'm seeing Kate with her
worried eyes
um it's going to be like a buzz across
the floor I mean we've heard it before
yeah I mean I think I think think that's
a good point Mr chair I think it would
be nice to have a little more of the
data analysis done under the amendment
to help give us as a subcommittee
reassurances you know that we be a
united front we're either for the
amendment or not and so that we send a
clear message to everyone else that yes
this amendment is different than the
original bill that we all were behind
but here's why it's good or here's why
it's not
good I have no problem we have three
bills three swept bills in
uh other swep bills if we took the swep
bill out of
this I would be happy I'm talking about
the
excess the Rand decision if we if if we
if we took the Rand decision out of this
and just did the conville with this I
would be happier but came when we
discussed it with the Department of
Education their judgments are all
wrapped in together so I would I will ha
I will have
modify this based on what ways and means
to us but we can't change the Rand
decision I mean that's that's why
everybody's hair's on fire right so I I
am I'm concurring with you this could be
a better Amendment without that and then
we fight that fight over here because
we've already lost that
fight yeah go
ahead when we lost that fight we weren't
consistently doing re-evaluations every
5 years and I thought as a result of
losing that fight and people got to keep
their swept
excess um by doing the fiveyear
reeval communities were doing this in an
equal methodology and Dr has a system
that they apply so that argument would
become
mute in terms of if the swep people set
excess swep people all of a sudden say
I'm keeping my money I'm not giving it
up am I making any sense Jack but they
can't you see that's right I
right I'm I'll happily redraft this with
the swept excess swept out of it but I
don't but I'd like to hear from Rick and
yeah yeah representative Heath I'm not
sure if I follow the history with the I
know that we do a 5-year evaluation if
you're talking about swear uh uh
fairness in the property values um I I
think there has been litigation and
course core cases relative to that I'm
just not fully up to speed on that um
I'm not either I only know the ran
litigation which is um the the order we
just got down which did not did not deal
process okay knowing that we are knowing
we are going to re reconvene on this
does anybody have anything they'd like
to
add can we hear it from Rick and and
David just I'm just I'm just commenting
we're going to reconvene I mean we're
not voting on this do you does anybody
from education want to make
mic
move it around the table just to try to
help better Define what transpired in
policy okay uh so you can get a grasp on
where the money has been added to the
current formula in what places so as
soon as everybody has
that then we can look at that and and
and and discuss it and there's a lot of
moving Parts in all this and and seeing
this other one right
here a lot more moving parts so you
didn't see this before I saw that
earlier
today but the issue is I think that we
have three bills sitting over there in
ways means right now which are dealing
with swep that's why we tabled one Bild
the other day seeing that and I spoke to
it on the floor we have three over there
let see what's going to come out of ways
and means but taking this sheet right
here the one you I just passed
out there's several columns there and
where you see the X's is where we made
some changes in the given year for
example effective July 1
2024 we made changes for the relief
Grant the fiscal capacity disparity Aid
and going down into 1656 we made changes
reference to the uh differentiated Aid
with the weighted values let's talk
about the the areas where we changed on
the right hand and you can see what we
did we added
into effective July 1 20125 that's where
we changed the base from base cost from
where we are now what's it's at
4,186 something thereabouts and we we
jumped it by $220 $22 per pupil to
$444 if you look at the second sheet
we'll come back to the front the second
sheet shows you how we did that we did
it in conjunction the way it's been done
for a decade going back to 2008 we
looked at the esbr report we looked at
what we did in 20171 18 and we modified
that we went and found out what is the
minimum average teacher cost in this
state today the average minimum teacher
42,5 you can go to some towns where it's
over 50,000 55,000 go to some others and
it's down as low as
32,000 so we took that average and then
we use the same factors for increasing
it for benefits and for um the the uh
relationship whether they're in an
elementary K through three we changed it
to K through three instead of K through
two so the ratio in K through 2 used to
be 1 to 25 students that's what we're
funding at the pupil teacher ratio we
felt that K through three are line
closer and four through 60 intermediate
grades Middle School grades going up
that's all at the 1 to30 level you can
see on this back side of that sheet we
did it for the administr for the
principal we went and found the average
cost of a principal in the state today
$100,000 Plus
103.3 the other categories were
increased equivalently to how we
increased teachers and principles based
upon the same percentage and and with
the other items on the backside which
deal with instructional materials and
teacher professional development all
those areas from back in 2008 now been
increased by about
16% so you can see that if you're in
that on those two columns on the right
hand side on the back page there you can
see that it's one for per pupil K
through three and then per pupil 4
through 12 the cost per pupil would be $
44700 for K through3 and for 4 through
12 which is really contrary to a lot of
people think it's more expensive in on
the high school but it ain't because
they can put more kids in Block classes
and and PE Etc it's 4265 the universal
cost which we've used remember we
started out years ago at
$3,456 that was based on the on the EST
report it'd be
4404 so that's what we used to calculate
the our formula when we were going back
to the front page for the FY 26 column
we kept the other column at the what we
would be projecting according to our
current Formula you can see going down
in both of those columns we jumped it by
$25 million that's the relief Grant
that's on the right side right of hold
harmless
so it's it's going to be allocated out
based upon free and reduced meals
starting at 12% and going up to
48% we had something like that back in
2008 when we were looking at um fiscal
capacity disparity 8 the fiscal capacity
disparity Aid that we have here however
is based upon the equalized valuation
per P per per admr and it goes from and
and and Dave worked on this one uh goes
from nine uh it starts at
$800,000 goes up to $1.9 th000 that's
what we basically been using for Ed
education relief grants right now and so
you can see how that's allocated the Max
Grant is $900 so that came out to $39
million adding on and of course you can
see what we did with special ed you'll
get the 1656 when your boss here is
ready to go that direction but you can
calculate where we were for FY 26 you
you can add the 35 the 25 and the 39 you
come up to roughly around $99
million and and then and you can see
what we had for FY 25 it started up to
add 25 the 39 and um you would add in
that well later the the special yeah no
it's the addition of the base that case
yes it's the it's the base which adds up
for the FY 26 from fy2 that's what we
wanted to do is we wanted to go back and
look at the original formula and look at
those inputs make sure we're adjusting
them to where we are
today and then on the special ed if you
want me to briefly explain that
representative you're not there yet what
I'd like to do is is suspend this
conversation on
1583 and open the discussion on
1656 because we can vote that one yes
we're not going to vote this one today
1656 so so you're in 1656 right now now
I'm in 1656 I'll briefly explain it and
Dave might want to add in some things we
passed several bills of L several last
years where we're recognizing for those
13 IEP
categories one amount of money doesn't
really meet those categories which are
higher cost categories like traumatic
brain injury orthopedically handicap and
you know there's 13 of them everything
from developmentally delayed to
disabilities I see Rebecca here um she
could explain the various categories I
could too but I I think we're moving
quickly here what we did is we then
asked how many kids do we have in
special ed under differentiated Aid and
you can see on the last sheet third
sheet
down
the figures
which Caitlyn uses over at doe show more
figures in special ed than we would see
out of the report out of the special ed
folks they use a one-time shot where he
takes an average shot so the average
shot is
3,965 kids we're projecting for the
years that we're dealing with here in
this budget and of that we see we broke
down these categories and con Junction
with how school districts are reporting
back to doe and doe to the federal
government regarding the individual
disability educations act there's a an
area where we have to report based upon
these three categories uh 80% or more
the time spent in special education less
79% down and actually she goes 79 to 40%
less than that down we went 79% down and
that's category B and then the
uh the last category is our
homeschooling kids and and or those in
hospitalization or those are not
homeschooling but uh
homebased hospital or residential 619
kids and we waited that more seeing that
is a much Co more costly program so we
rided it wait weighted it according to
the first category is weighted at a
6 of the base 1.2 is the second category
and 1.8 is the third base so you can see
what those costs come out to be when
you're using that
444 it comes out to $2600 $5,200
$7,900 for those three
categories this does not take into
account anything to do with catastrophic
Aid that $33 million or so that you have
to have available for when you get into
children question um just with regard to
Charter children children charter
schools with disabilities The Local
School District covers the cost of um
our Charter kids ascending school yes
right so how res resident school so will
we apply the same formula to the
children in charter schools and that
money then I'm presuming will come back
to the local school district yes thank
you
absolutely other
questions
1656 the number that was that I pulled
million you're and but this is this is
looking like $101
million somewhere between cup and lift
something didn't make
no that's the total that's the total
about okay so I'm not crazy the
current the current amount is $66
million we're spending right now by
doing the changes here you would would
add on that additional dollars to get to
that 101 million so you're you're
increasing it by a total of $40 million
give well you're increasing it by uh $
34.3 million okay that's I mean
represent doesn't have we have detailed
level data and we we work
with level data with the student with a
disability and U linked it up with the
individual student we have different
number so we spend more time going over
represent a glads methodology but we
just have a different number
so different then I guess we're not
going to vote for this one today either
because also we need more time because
this is we like to provide language to
change this because there's going to be
a lag in the way we get the data from
the sped Bureau so we probably need to
have a two-year lag in the SP data if we
were to implement this bill which
so all right so this one goes on the
Shelf till our next meeting as well good
all right does anybody have any comments
they like to make about this
1656 question we got the we got all the
talent here I just wanted to say that I
followed along with the subcommittee's
discussions about special ed and
differentiating the aid into three
different categories and I just wanted
to thank the committee for doing that
work I think um it's probably long
overdue and um I know that there will be
communities across our state who will
appreciate this move if we do end up
taking that way thank
you I also sat in you know list or on
Zoom zoomed into it um and really
support and appreciate the work that
they did with this I mean I think it's
it's long overdue and I'm frustrated to
hear that there's such a lag before we
can actually start to implement
it
that was the first time we've been able
to put a committee together with people
from Ways and Means finance and policy
and that I think we I really appreciate
your W willingness to let us use this
room representa Emer and representative
Heath um I I think it re really got us
to where we wanted to get quicker when
we had the three groups working
together can I add sure um that's I
think I want to Echo um representative
Heath's concern too is that it was
remarkable to see the bipartisan ship
and everyone working together to pull
together is it what 586
583 and so I don't want to lose that
although there's so much I like about
the Emer Amendment um I'm hoping we'll
have time to merge these together but I
would like that subcommittee to weigh in
on how we can pull this together as to
one thing because I very much appreciate
what you did and watching the
bipartisanship in that subcommittee was
remarkable okay do you want to make any
other comments about either one of these
bills
no that we've been working for years on
weighted
formula for special education and it's
well over 39 states to have a weighted
formula they're just recognizing there's
so many different needs for the various
categories and using what we used with
it we do have data available we
initially tried to do it by individual
categories but then students according
to the director here are times sometimes
overlapping between categories and they
may have multiple handicap how do you do
that this way we've got the information
this okay so yes I think Bri Bri Wasing
on this I think there's maybe some we
might have two different data sets
represent so that could be the
discrepancy figure out why the numbers
are 11656 but but somebody commented
that it needed this 1656 needed an
amendment needs probably some Amendment
on when we deter when we collect this B
data there's a discrepancy between when
they collect it and when we use it for
so you're going to help me put that
together
okay yes it's taking
us away from leg to get away from the
three-year leg I I'd hate to kind of go
back to a two-year lag yeah so the the
issue with the lag is the more we lag
the more accurate the data is I know but
also the less current it is so it's kind
of a tradeoff
much all right does anybody want to have
1583 I let not speak now or forever hold
your peace because we're going to
reconvene on this
PE I just want to say it's very exciting
to get to that number of the 7.3 I
didn't think we could get there
well it takes Finance man we don't know
anything at
all by all means yeah thank you Mr chair
what do you see as a work path for um
for 1583 and 1656 going
forward what do I what do you see is a
work path for both these we right now we
we're not going to have a meeting next
week because it's election day right uh
and the chairman is busy on Wednesday
with Health and Human Services we have
we don't know if next th but they won't
tell us today whe there's a
session because it could be the it could
be that day could be Thursday Thursday
Thursday the 14th
weet and that would be work sessions yes
okay thank you yeah it wouldn't be
executing be work sessions
okay we'll shoot for that date but if we
have if we have session then it's right
have to do it next week right
we just need to coordinate
well yeah we're running out of time here
that um those the 20th
is isn't it the 20th you have to have
all your committee reports done by noon
because the 21st is the date they're
supposed to be submitted but I can't
imagine going much later than that Well
Finance does strange things do you have
one
April Alo so that's for that that was
for second committee bills okay that
gives us a little yeah we have a little
longer
yeah
good well as we're going to do it as
soon as we can but you know but what
right yes and just as an aside we're all
holding that day for house session so if
it's not house it can be here yes um I
guess I'd like to ask um
there are a lot of stakeholders Beyond
division two of finance that are
involved in this um you know some of
them are here but to make sure that
those stakeholders are also involved to
bring in their knowledge of um basically
you know the education and the formula
the lawsuits but um just to make sure
that we have stakeholders that can
answer the questions that will be here
um I was sort of envisioning um an
equitable kind of group of people
that're working on this as opposed to
you know a hearing sort of a thing
although I guess that's basically what a
yeah before we go to full committee I
think a lot of us would like to
understand better how these two things
will work together since we have to
present that to the full committee and
to have that stakeholder input I think
is really important as opposed to us
sort of talking about it when we know
there are people who know way more than
some of us know well we'll have we'll
have to notice the meeting anyway so
though Mr chair I just wanted to ask if
we could get clarification on one
particular data point point for the next
work session on
1583 could we could we just find out
what the fiscal impact of increasing the
base from the
73561 just yeah so so I know
4,182 the com oh good
point okay yeah thank
you did you get your question answered
just like
that Holy 4
probably and this is effective fiscal
year
205 266 sorry thank you okay so it go
into
July
1 Mr chair you're you're you're talking
about the base in 1583 is July 1 of what
my oh 2025 I'm sorry not
I didn't see it in the that's
didn't
400 okay anybody want to have any other
questions or comments at this time then
we could we'll adjourn both Bill
hearings to a not date
certain
uh but sometime as soon as we can all
[Music]
right we could meet on the morning of
the 15th you meet in the afternoon now
fiscal yeah but what time: oh well could
the it be somewhere that week
Monday that doesn't work either oh Mr ch
can go right ahead and schedule however
there well if we can we'll meet on the
14th if not we'll meet on the 18th on
the 18 must be something on the
afternoon
okay
well all right to the all right thank
you all great thank you thanks for
coming
in